Tuition by one new laptop and one Imac,
right?
Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by the fleshlight.
If you've got a Joe rogan.net and Click on the wink for the flashlight and enter
in the code name Rogan,
you will get 15% off the number one sex toy for men.
He'd call a sex toy.
But it's not a toy.
It's fucking serious shit,
right Brian?
It's a friend.
It's a friend sex friend for men.
It's a friend with no mouth.
All Right,
ladies and gentlemen,
Tim Ferriss is in the house.
We're going to get down to the nitty gritty.
We're going to learn some shit.
We're gonna figure this out together and experience together.
Bitches run the music.
[inaudible]
the power of the internet once again manifest itself or causes things to
manifest or whatever.
Tim Ferriss here,
Ladies and gentlemen.
Yeah.
Thanks for having me.
Thanks for coming man.
And a much requested a man on the Internet because a lot of people really enjoy
your work and you got some,
uh,
some fascinating theories and uh,
some,
uh,
you've,
you've obviously spent a lot of time breaking things down and analyzing things
and you know,
people really love that they love when someone does the hard work
harness my OCD for something useful.
Is that what it is?
I don't think it's,
it's a diagnosed,
but I'm glad,
certainly when I was a kid,
the ADHD didn't have a prescription associated in a label with it.
Cause I would have been thrown straight into a,
I would have a page I would have as well for sure.
But here's the thing,
man,
there's nothing wrong with you.
There's nothing wrong with you at all.
Why is it that people want to medicate someone for being unusual or exceptional
or energetic or someone who can't sit and do boring shit?
They,
they,
they resist the machine.
So we tell them they're sick.
Yeah.
No,
because if you'll sit in some boring,
monotonous class about some fucking subject,
you don't really give a shit about your instincts as a five year old kid or a
six year old kid is to run out of the room or even 15 or whatever the f even
now,
that's normal.
That's like you don't want to be around shit.
It's not stimulating,
but we're like,
there's something wrong with you if you don't submit to the hive.
Yeah,
there's something wrong with you.
Oh,
you can't?
What?
Do you want to write your own books?
No,
no,
no.
You got to memorize all the shit that we wrote.
We don't want you coming up with music.
We don't want you figuring out movies or cartoons or starting your own comic
book.
Did,
did,
did.
He can't call a guy who writes books like you do.
You can't say you have OCD,
dude.
You don't get a disease.
No,
no,
not at all.
It is.
One of my friends,
I remember in,
I think it was third grade,
he was one of the smarter kids in the class and he got bored out of his mind,
so he took a fork,
walked over to the side of the room.
The teacher was on the blackboard and he goes,
I am the master of the universe,
and he stabbed the fork into the electric outlet and shot.
So he was immediately lead into the dispelled from the class for a period of
time,
but he was one of the smarter kids in the class.
It was just boring.
Oh,
and the classic only move is as quickly as the slowest kid and he was born.
I've done that with before.
I took a wire to
the top outlet and and wanted to transfer the power from the top outlet to the
bottom.
I was like,
why?
I want to see if I could do this,
and I did it and just blew up.
Flew across the room.
That's what they use for cooking hot dogs at science fairs.
Explains a little bit more about Brian.
Joe,
we found another link in front.
Another little piece of evidence.
The missing puzzle.
Yeah,
man,
school is boring as fuck.
That's a big problem.
A big problem when it's not addressed because we figure,
well fuck it,
I got out of it.
They can get out of it too.
I went through all that boring shit.
You go through all that boring shit too,
but it is the worst way to inform the mind ever does make it so it sucks and
it's boring and you have to get up early when you're tired and be around some
uninspired fucks of beginning paid pennies to teach you this nonsense.
I slept through them.
I honestly can say I slept through at least 80 to 90% of all of my school high
school years.
Like my dad gave me this camel cigarette hat that back in the day you were
allowed to wear a cigarette hats to school and stuff.
Yeah.
He's like,
some guy at work gave this to me.
Do you want this?
He,
my dad doesn't smoke and so I was like,
okay,
and so I wore my whole,
you smoked?
No,
it was before I smoke.
He gave it to me.
Like I worked my whole four years of high school.
It was kind of cool but it,
cause no one had cigarette hats I guess.
Right.
But I found that way folded perfectly.
Where like if I sat like look the right way,
it looks like I was looking at my book.
And so I s I mastered all through high school,
but the problem is now I'm trying to learn things that I should have learned
already.
Like the Holocaust and the civil war and started academy.
Have you seen Khan Academy?
No.
K.
H a n academy.
It's astonishing.
And this,
uh,
gentleman who decided he wanted to teach his kids,
I think it was remotely about calculus or something like that to help them with
their schooling.
And then he ended up blowing it off for the entire world.
And now it has gates support.
And what some of these charter schools,
the most successful charter schools are doing is they're actually taking the
lecture piece of school,
which puts kids in sleep.
They're signing that as homework.
And then when the kids come in,
they focus on projects and experiments and actually putting what they heard and
learned in a practice pretty,
if that makes sense.
That seems like a lot better approach than just sitting there with a monotone
voice pointing at chalkboards and going through a huge books and looking at
stupid pictures nowadays.
I think that would be pretty good at school because it be interactive with like
iPads and stuff like that.
I think that that's probably a lot better than it was when we went to high
school or
why do you think they use iPads in class?
Yeah.
A lot of schools are your life goals.
You're given iPads really nowadays.
Real.
I'm pretty wild stuff.
Yeah.
That's pretty awesome.
You remember when you used to get a movie and like science class,
you are so excited.
Fuck yeah,
movie,
man.
This is going to be good.
I'm going to get some pleasure out of this as opposed to this normal nonsense
with this asshole.
Just droning on with those like sex ed when no one was comfortable enough to
present the material,
they'll be like,
all right,
now we're going to watch some like breaches.
I don't think we had sex ed.
I don't think I ever had sex ed.
I don't think I did in Massachusetts.
I don't,
I don't believe they taught a sex Ed.
I really don't.
I don't remember a goddamn thing.
That projector movie of like uh,
your body.
The penis as good against the chin.
Maybe they did and I blocked it out,
but I don't remember out of my four years of Newton south high school,
I don't remember anybody telling me anything about sex.
Not a fucking peep.
It was just nonsense.
Just droning on,
become a part of the machine.
Submit.
You are around peg,
you are not a square peg.
As I remember,
a lot of school was watching movies and they were all made by Disney.
Do you remember that?
Like they would like and now the natural forest
and it was like,
wait,
the Disney raised me back then to like
if you raise kids with fascinating documentaries he would,
they would learn so much more that I've learned so much more from documentaries
as long as it's verifiable.
If it's like a legit documentary,
you can get a little crazy and fun.
Some documentaries on on worms,
those flying worms in the air.
If you're a fucking man,
dad is one of the greatest things ever.
Do you know about this now there was a guy who was absolutely convinced that
there was these things.
He called them rods and they were flying around us too fast for us to see and
that you could only capture these things on video tape that the human,
I was incapable of registering cause they were going so fast and that they look
like almost like jelly fish with winged appendages.
This guy spent years in years and this shit and made documentaries about it,
had a website dedicated to it and then monster quest found out that these things
were just video artifacts when bugs flew too close to the lens.
So this guy,
his whole life,
he had dedicated to a video artifacts and he thought there was cs flying,
tubular fluorescent looking for,
or not fluorescent,
but uh,
the translucent looking a things flying.
Do you imagine the stress and like obligation to society?
This guy felt only to find out that that's a video artifact thought they were.
He aliens,
they're flying around this.
We just,
we just can't register them.
It's like those flares and pictures that people think are ghosts.
You know,
there's obvious to proof what they are,
but yet people still have no,
no,
no.
Did you my spirit,
how fascinating was Pinchbeck saying that ghosts were real Lincoln Raven.
I didn't get raped by the way.
I wanted to put that on record.
I offered the ghost to rape my ass all night to go story.
Yeah,
no,
goes rape me.
That night.
Guy On the other day was absolutely convincing.
Costs are really so,
so smart and every other way.
And I'm like,
wow,
ghosts really like ghost stories.
There is some weird stuff out there though.
Like a meaning.
One of the reasons I ended up going to Princeton Undergrad,
but one of the reasons I wanted to go,
which I didn't tell people cause that that they'd make fun of me was because of
a lab called the scientific anomalies laboratory.
I'm not making this up.
And they had statisticians,
mathematicians looking at stuff like bigfoot remote,
not big foot.
Uh,
the huge yeah,
remote viewing.
Exactly.
So they looked at
remote viewing really closely and uh,
professor John who ran this entire a research lab gave his wrap up speech before
they closed.
Like the year I landed at school and he was talking about,
for example,
with the remote viewing for people who don't know what it is,
you have a transmitter.
It who goes out with the field team.
Then you have a receiver in a room with a pad of paper and a recorder.
The job of the transmitter,
they,
they choose one of five envelopes.
They get gps coordinates,
they go to that location and then they take the imagery and they transmit it to
the person who's supposed to be a receiver.
And what they found with one location a is an example,
the drawings came back very consistent with the best receivers,
but they were at a gas station and it wasn't like,
I think it was the gas station,
it wasn't a gas station in the picture and they couldn't identify what it was.
And I ended up being barracks that had been destroyed like 120 years ago.
Something like that.
Pretty Wild Shit.
Um,
the,
there was an accurate depiction of these things.
The drawings were consistent,
consistent,
and it was an accurate depiction.
Uh,
doesn't the government employ a bunch of people to,
I listen to art bell coast to coast am,
that's where I get my information.
But I've,
I've heard on several occasions that the government as employed people to be
remotely
viewers and Oh yeah,
they'd go submarines in particular.
Yeah.
Really?
This,
uh,
the,
so there's something to it.
There's like start off international,
a bunch of research institutes that have been funded by the government for that
particular purpose.
And I think that the math is compelling.
I mean the data are compelling.
So you look at,
for example,
they had this huge,
it looked like a Pachinko machine.
I saw it in person.
So if you see these Japanese pinball machines,
they're vertical and have these pins and then these small steel balls bounce
down,
you have to get them in somewhere.
And uh,
and this thing's about 10 feet high,
maybe five feet wide.
And the objective of the person who is the subject was simply to get the balls
to deviate to the left or right hand column.
That's all you had to do.
And so the ren thousands and thousands and thousands of trials looking at what
doesn't affect telekinesis and they were able to show that,
you know,
with both the a p value significance value,
those very compelling.
Like there's no way,
there's almost no way you can attribute this to chance if you,
if you crunch all the data.
Pretty wild stuff.
But it doesn't mean I can move stuff around my eyes.
Well,
if we,
you know,
we actually talked about this very recently,
that the idea of um,
being able to watch something and that the observer actually changes the
particles,
changes subatomic particles and changes the way they interact with their
environment.
And that's if that,
if that's happening on some level somewhere and a very small level,
it must be an ethic that permeates through the whole thing.
Yeah.
We probably just are slowly evolving and developing this ability to ultimately
alter everything around us.
We just,
right now we're in this,
you know,
fishy arm,
leg co crawling out of the water stage,
you know,
we're just like those freaky things that made their way out of the ocean and it
became land down in the house.
Yeah.
I think that there's,
yeah,
there's a lot of evolution left.
I think the physical side,
obviously it's sort of cut
off once you have all the,
the creature comforts and Maslow's hierarchy candle,
then you don't have to breed for physical fitness necessarily.
But I think certainly with toxins and whatnot,
like that's going to force people to evolve environmental toxins and the
estrogen,
endocrine disruptors and all that.
They're going to figure out a way to do everything that you and I do in the gym
in a fucking shot.
You know?
It's going to be real simple.
It's going to be,
we're just going to program your body to operate at this level.
You don't need to go to the gym.
You know what?
I need to do anything and you're going to walk around looking like aqua man.
Oh sure.
How that's going to happen.
Or like they're going to laugh with people that lift weights.
Like you get what?
You fucking dummy.
Why didn't you just take the shot?
Just go take a shot.
Seeing some pretty wild stuff with gene therapy in the course of doing the
foreign body and meeting with all these athletes.
I mean I've,
I've written about,
you know,
how I've used a GH and antibiotics and different things postsurgery among other
times,
but the most fascinating thing I saw it,
I think it's probably the most dangerous also is interleukin and gene therapy.
I know one guy,
I won't mention them,
this is actually an MMA fighter.
Ended up going to China to have gene therapy performed and you used interleukin
therapy gain almost 40 pounds of muscle in one month.
And that was with no change to his training or diet gene therapy.
So what they do is they'll take let's say 40 pounds of muscle in a month.
How does his heart not explore?
Right?
How's this heart all of a sudden working for 30,
40 extra pounds?
Exactly.
So there are a lot of risks involved.
Of course,
he's also taking things like g h,
uh,
IGF one,
et Cetera,
vitamin D.
But the,
uh,
what's fascinating about the gene therapy,
you can also use like vector based viruses to increase muscle synthesis and
specific areas of the body.
So the hope is of course that that doesn't then malfunction and lead your heart
or intestines to hypertrophy cause then you end up looking like some of these
pro bodybuilders who were like,
that's crazy.
Like whoa,
that's so weird.
Just the word to the wise if you're going to use,
uh,
something like t h and there's,
there are definitely places to do that.
Uh,
you know,
watch the dosages.
Cause if you have organ growth that's not going to reverse as muscular growth.
When I approached free wood,
uh,
but you look after my reconstructive shoulder surgery,
I used a high frequency low dose growth hormone is twice a day,
six days a week and would absolutely do it again in a heartbeat.
Absolutely.
You to no reservations whatsoever.
But yeah,
I mean that's just step one.
You know,
what this is is it's,
it's genetic manipulation at a very base level.
It's like we're just adding chemicals that don't,
they don't make any chemicals into my,
what's add them.
We make our own.
Then we scored them in there.
Yeah.
And then the glands don't know what the fuck's going on.
Like,
why is there this?
That's why I dude's like in MMA fighters,
there's several different occurrences of this where guys are very young and they
have to get on testosterone.
And uh,
it could be a natural issue.
It could be a,
you know,
something happened to them when they were young and you know,
their,
their testicles never fully developed.
Or it could be that they took steroids and they shocked fucking shit out of
their
system to the point where your ball shut down.
Yeah.
That happens to dudes.
It's pretty common,
man.
Yeah.
Common,
especially if you're doing the black market and you don't have proper post
psychotherapy,
you don't know how to use,
let's say Clomid or one of these don't the fuck you're doing and you still go to
a dog,
don't go to a doctor,
your blood levels,
and then you stop cold Turkey.
It's like stupid stupid.
You see a lot of incidences also where it appears that a testosterone molecule
Saas drone binds with,
uh,
let's say in some cases dopamine receptors.
So when people take antidepressants,
also serotonin's involved,
uh,
antidepressants plus testosterone really can be a really nasty combo.
Whoa.
Yeah.
So you see these cases of let's say,
suppose it roid rage or people committing suicide.
They blame it on anabolics.
It's actually the combination of,
let's say an antianxiety or antidepressive with the antibiotic.
I know guys who are on both.
It's dangerous.
Yeah.
And they're dangerous.
Guys do
not dangerous.
Brian's been on the juice for a couple of months.
I take them to the squat rack every day after the show.
Oh God.
It's my vagina.
Heart
shows on the toilet just started.
The genetic manipulation that we're doing though with adding testosterone or
adding estrogen,
adding anything is nothing compared to what it's going to be like when they
figured that shit out of genetic level and they know how to engineer the body
and they figure out how to make your cells literally become 20 year old cells.
They bring your whole body to a state of where it was when you were at your peak
of youth.
That's so possible,
man.
They're so close to that.
They're within a lifetime.
In our lifetime.
By the time we,
you know,
grow old and die,
they're going to have figured out a way that no one grows,
all think they're within 10 years of figuring a lot of that out.
So crazy.
You're going to have like old ladies that all of a sudden become hot again.
Do you know how bad ass that would be?
Yeah,
if there was this,
oh Jesus,
don't be mean.
Don't be mean Brian.
Yeah,
she was good.
I know you're talking about if you like,
there was an old lady and she lived on your blog and she was all hunched over
and shit.
And then over the course of like a couple of months,
all of a sudden her posture came back,
pop up,
up,
up.
Her ass started sticking out and she started turning into a young woman again.
She was a 50 year old kind of semi hot lady and then all of a sudden the next
couple of weeks she's a 40 year old hot lady.
You know,
like what the fuck is going on?
It would be fine.
Have a fixed everything.
But the next thing you know,
she's his 80 year old mind,
but with this hot 20 year old body that would be on mother fucker having
marriages threatened from both.
My husband left me for an 80 year old and eight year old
mortal.
If it made the vagina and everything grow back to young age,
it'd be perfect in all right.
Oh,
the whole body.
It wouldn't,
it wouldn't just leave the vagina.
Our team got good news.
Good news is you can be 20 again.
The bad news is your vagina has to stay 90 yeah,
but what'd you do?
What'd you teeth or would it do?
Well,
the idea is she going to get hot chick that's pooping all the time because she
can't control her poop.
Why is it going to do everything?
Well,
yeah.
Well then if you have a,
does your whole body makes your whole body younger.
Whatever issues you have that are age related will go away because you won't
have hormonal deficiencies anymore.
You know what keep funny though is that if like she still liked hard candy and
pie,
the hot young chick,
but she liked like old rhubarb,
our pies and you're like,
I like Rhubarb Pie,
creepy food,
Dan.
Like what do I stuff carrots?
Like she says,
I just love mashed up carrots with my vitamins.
You know,
like she had all the behaviors of an 80 year old.
I wonder if she was still using a walker with the tennis balls.
Still like to watch more little bitch.
When you see people that are cranky and old,
old shitty people,
the reason most of them are like that,
it's because their life is miserable.
Their body feels like shit.
It's falling apart.
Every day is just act.
I'll fuck off my lawn,
you know?
But if you all of a sudden gave them gene therapy and their body became 20 I
wonder if their behavior would revert to a 20 year old behavior again,
just,
you know,
obviously a little more experienced,
but yeah,
you would,
right?
You wouldn't be able to be here like almost a racing memories then why?
Because it's you're,
you're,
it's,
you're saying that you're getting younger,
so it's going,
you're going to act younger and that's meaning like,
you're just forgetting that you're not old.
They don't know.
You would still have experienced,
so you'd still have life experience,
but you would have,
you'd be a lot of what people do.
They fucking woo.
A lot of that is just extra energy that you have.
You know,
a lot of,
a lot of dumb shit that young people do.
It's just,
they're all charged up with life.
You know,
they're charged up with life and all day long they're either stuck behind a desk
or some unnatural thing for their body.
And then when they get out at night,
they want to fuck woo.
That it's just,
you know,
it's firing it off.
As you get older,
you have less and less of that shit.
You know,
you're the only time you see like a 50 year old guy.
There's like when he's just about to get arrested.
No,
he has to be so drunk.
He's already punched out.
Do you know who I am?
Stage where they're dragging them out?
You mother fucker.
You know,
my cousin is,
yeah,
your life energy.
It's not just being clueless is also this bursting in Ferno of shit inside you
because you're 20 years old and your body's alive.
I think with the,
with the reversal of some of the symptoms of aging,
looking at telomeres and all that stuff,
I think a lot of it will be combined with regenerative medicine.
Sona,
some guys who are printing,
I mean I've seen them print heart cells and lung cells and so forth.
So my,
my theory is that if you can keep your neural,
your neurological functioning,
um,
and,
and at at a high level and mitigate stuff like Parkinson's,
Alzheimer's,
et Cetera,
that you'll ultimately be able to get a replacement for just about anything
else.
So the simplest,
the simplest approach,
and this has been looked at for a decade or more,
is creating monohydrate.
Actually five grams a day for a
reaper staving off Alzheimer's and Parkinson's is three a team,
their clinical studies.
So you can go on pub,
pub med or medline and look them up.
They've done a lot of research,
how much,
what is the dosage of very low,
like five grams.
You,
you'd get creative Glen Creatine to prevent the water attention.
So I had read something and Creatine,
you know,
like people would always say that it makes you gain water and people would say
that it's not good for your liver.
But then I read online,
there's no evidence is not good for your liver.
There's no evidence.
It's bad for you.
I'm like,
well,
where'd that come from?
Where'd the the rumor come from?
Is that pharmaceutical companies or something?
Like what is the,
I think it started with wives tales.
Uh,
it started with few things.
I think the first is that if you have a preconditioning kidney problems,
so it's a kidney issue,
but then here's what happens is then people substitute,
let's say at one point in a forum or thread liver.
And so they'll,
you hear about the liver a lot,
but it's actually not affected,
uh,
with the creatine,
as long as you don't have renal insufficiency or some really major kidney issue,
I,
I've really,
it's one of the most innocuous supplements you could take.
From my perspective,
I really don't think it will cause much problem.
I used to take that shit before Google as the problem took it before Google.
I thought it actually is bad for you.
People like,
don't do the fucking crew teens bad for your live liver was like,
I'm like,
oh,
it is.
Oh,
I know.
Before he could do any factcheck.
Creatine is good.
It makes you gain weight.
I gained a lot of weight.
I gained like five pounds of muscle using this stuff.
It really does make you gain weight because it's,
it makes your somehow or another,
your body retains more water and your cells are mostly water,
so it just makes your cells bigger.
You actually get physically cocksucker sodium cock sucker.
Um,
what was I going to ask you?
You were talking about,
I said Tiller arms.
What is the telomeres,
telomeres,
do you know about Ti ta 65?
Uh,
yeah,
I was that bullshit.
What does,
it's not necessarily bullshit.
I just don't think it's explained to people what it is.
So yeah,
ta 65 is an approach to in long gating or protecting the deterioration of the
caps of telomeres.
So this is related to sort of chromosomal aging and Tia 65 is it's expensive.
I don't know what the prices are now,
but it's an approach that is supposed to be,
at least in rodents if demonstrated it able to,
uh,
extend the functional lifespan of your telomeres.
Like that's a good way if you look at telomeres and how they slowly,
uh,
shorten over time,
you could almost think of it like rings on a tree,
right?
So just in the opposite direction,
like the shorter your telomeres are,
the closer you are to your end point a ta 65,
my feeling is there,
there hasn't been enough widescale testing that I would feel comfortable using
it myself.
Um,
exceptionally comfortable.
Uh,
let's say using a moderate,
you know,
responsible use of antibiotics and different types depending on your thyroid,
potentially thyroid,
and then combining that with creating and a few other things.
But,
uh,
personally I would not use tsxd five at this point.
Uh,
I've,
I've don't know,
I know one guy who used it,
but I only know him online and I know him in real life,
but his,
uh,
bad,
Bobby,
his dad started using it and his dad started getting really good results with
it.
Like,
so he stopped using it.
He just tried,
he said he didn't feel like it was doing anything for him,
but his dad apparently,
who's,
you know,
an older guy,
it's like,
it's helping them see better.
I have a buddy who's a,
who's using it and he's a,
you know,
CEO in Silicon Valley and he said that he's noticed gray hair turning black
again and things like that.
Whoa,
right hair,
right.
You have a crystal on his neck?
No,
no,
this is,
this is an engineer type.
He's,
he's no bs.
Uh,
but for me,
I'm happy to wait.
Like if this stuff works,
as people say it works well,
if I wait three years,
it doesn't matter.
Right,
right,
right.
Good point.
I'll let those Beta testers,
you don't throw fucking horns or whatever and then I'll be like,
yeah,
yeah.
They didn't tell you about the horns turned the chimpanzee
tea 65 is interesting though.
I mean,
what's also interesting is lobsters.
People look at lobsters to study life extension because they don't exhibit any
of the normal signs of aging.
So people,
there are people who believe that they would live for,
you know,
hundreds and hundreds of years if they weren't caught and killed.
Oh really?
Yeah.
What does the oldest one we've ever observed?
I don't know.
It's a good question.
I'll start taking lobster oil or something.
That's the next thing.
Lobster oil dishes.
I remember being high as fuck once at Morton's,
you know,
and Morton steak house,
they walked by with a cart and they show you this is the prime,
you know,
a sirloin cut in,
you can have it with this and that.
And then he holds up the lobster and the lobsters moving and barbecued.
I'm sitting there with Eddie Bravo.
We're both going to look at that motherfucker out of the debt alien thing that
he's holding up.
Like how buzz that fucking soulless emotionless creature,
that giant bug that lives in the ocean,
they're holding onto.
It doesn't even need to imagine the first guy
like I'm going to eat this.
Like the first guy who pulls that up in front of the villagers.
He's like,
yeah,
you guys,
I've had enough to drink.
I'm going to eat this.
That's a bold motherfucker.
Yeah.
So speaking of documentaries,
that'd be curious.
Do you have any particular top,
top favorites?
Wow.
All time favorites.
And the corporation was one of my all time.
I've heard this is good.
I haven't seen at Turbin fucking documentary Enron,
the smartest guys in the room.
That was a really grumpy motherfucker burn when California is going down.
Unbelievable guy who wasn't there.
It's pretty good.
Yeah,
that's,
I incorporated food is corporate guys.
Urban man on wire.
No,
I haven't seen it all.
That's about the tight rope walker.
Right.
But the guys who get,
who sneak into the World Trade Center and then tight rope walk across to the
other tower,
like between the two towers.
Oh my God.
Did he really?
And he made it.
He had,
they've,
they've video.
It's awesome.
Really.
That hurts my dick just sitting here thinking about it.
Oh yeah.
He not only walked across it,
he stayed up there for like 30 minutes or something and she laid down on the
wire then stood back up.
That was hard to watch.
These fucking guys have the limits of like physicality
when we really truly don't you?
No,
we don't.
No one is,
no one has really sort of a actualized the,
the,
the full potential of all the human athletic abilities like gymnastics and
basketball and track and field and fighting and you know,
eventually,
you know,
will people live long enough so one person could be like a master at all sports
and all games and all things
life extension.
That's why a lot of the,
the sort of singularity focused or just life extension focused,
uh,
tech CEO's,
guys who've made hundreds of millions of dollars,
they're pouring it into these startups,
they think we'll be able to make them live forever because that's what they see
is their rate limiting step for all learning all this stuff.
Well,
yeah,
I mean if you really think about it,
if you could live to be a thousand years old,
how many languages would you learn?
How many books would you read?
How many things would you be into?
How many things would you,
you know,
I don't believe you ever truly master anything.
You know,
you,
you get,
you master a certain level proficiency.
But there's always levels.
There's always levels above.
The is always more to learn.
But how amazing would it be to build,
accumulate a thousand years worth of information.
But then again,
maybe you just wasted your time spinning your wheels here and this stupid
dimension,
you know,
and that once we pop through to the next thing,
we're like,
why would it be waste any of our fucking time?
You were just playing with blocks and kindergarten just constrained by the
monkey ego tied into this fucking caveman body.
You know,
living with all these other savages,
shooting missiles at each other.
That's,
that's really what's going on.
They will for sure.
One day,
thousands of years from now,
the way we study Sumir and we looked at who studied Mesopotamia and we see that
the pictures of the carriages and how they rode into battle would fucking sticks
with big pieces of metal on the end of the sticks and how we go,
what could these fucking retards we,
they're gonna look at us like that too.
For sure.
100% right?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
For sure.
No doubt about it.
It's impossible to avoid.
Yeah.
I don't think we're a,
I dunno man.
Do you wonder what's going to happen between all this stuff?
Cause the life extension,
if you,
if,
if it actually becomes something mainstream and popular,
what,
what the fuck band.
No one's going to die and it's going to be way too many of us.
Almost immediate.
I think we'll have a pandemic in the next three years.
Do you think so really?
I think that whether it's,
whether it is naturally three years.
Ah,
I just,
I just think that if you look at the population density and the,
uh,
the technological capabilities and the cost of biotech,
so I had,
for example,
I asked,
hey,
a friend of mine,
he runs a publicly traded biotech company,
said I have a hundred of the best scientists in the world.
If we want it to end the world,
like we could do it.
Absolutely.
It's like,
give us six months.
We could,
we could engineer a,
you know,
a virus containing a,
B and c that would be communicable.
Just like the common cold.
We'd seen it in three or four months,
Paul and areas and a story.
He had a great idea.
What if you infuse the common cold with Lsd
so that as people,
as people,
it was it your idea or Dunkin Dunkins idea so that as you get the cold,
you also trip your fucking balls off and you could literally get a whole state
sick with ls.
Well,
you have,
well,
you'd have to find something that was either replicable by virus or by bacteria.
I'm sure there's something out there like maybe it's something naturally
occurring like 5:00 AM 5:00 AM you know,
DMT or something like that as opposed to,
you know,
less surgical Starbucks.
That's all it's going to be.
Yeah.
Well the thing I would think about what the reason why acid would be a good ones
because it's so small.
Let's you,
do you need such a small amount of it to affect you?
Yeah,
you could do it.
I think that,
uh,
you do need a very small amount.
If you,
if you were using,
let's say five Meo Dmt,
I'd say you could get away with as little as two milligrams.
Uh,
and particularly if it's self replicates.
So let's say the virus is tiny itself,
but then it builds up to an active dose by replication and your body.
Then you just need the variant,
like the Cedar,
the seeder to start
five meo GMC is a crazy thing to get people sick with because in acid when you
have acid,
you know,
as far as I understand,
you're still sort of there that the big thing about the five Meo DMT
experiences,
you don't,
you don't exist anymore.
It's like a near stop being there.
Yeah.
You go to some other place,
you,
you like,
you feel like your consciousness leaves your body and enters into some other
place so you wouldn't be paying attention to your body it all,
which is really a dangerous to get people sick that way.
If you engineered that,
you engineered some sort of a cold that gets people to just drop to the ground
and DMT trips.
That's just rude.
Yeah,
right.
That's what your objectives are for seeding a state with LSD.
Enlightenment.
Yeah.
That's ridiculous because most people use it for recreational purposes,
but I think any sort of a,
a mass ego erasing experience like that could only help people look September
11th was a terrible thing that,
that that happened.
It was,
it was horrible.
I knew people that knew people that died there.
I knew people,
I've talked to people that saw bodies hitting the ground.
Rent is easy was in that bill,
but what it would,
it did do and it was really strange was made everybody really nice for a while.
Everybody was really like friendly and neighborly and there was a real sense in
New York of everybody being together in a way that I never felt there before.
It was always the New York is always like Donald Logan man fuck you out of my
way.
There was always in this,
this thing that happens when you have this a diffusion of responsibility because
of the population numbers are so high.
It just,
you'd get this non non feeling and friendly environment,
you know,
it's impossible to interact with everyone so you just fucking put your blinders
on you.
He pressed ahead,
but that,
that terrible experience was ego dissolving a lot of ways and it humbled a lot
of people and it made people appreciate life and it made people appreciate all
the,
all the people around them.
And it was fucking terrible,
terrible tragedy.
But what a beautiful time I had right after that tragedy in New York.
I remember I was there a few months later.
I was like,
wow,
everybody is so cool.
I hope this sticks.
That's all I remember thinking,
I hope this sticks,
man.
I hope people realize,
you know,
we should all be like this.
We should all be like brothers and sisters and friendly to each other and
firefighters should get laid.
There should be checks that are fun trying to blow.
Firefighters were all fired up,
you know,
cause for awhile firefighters were fucking rock stars in New York and then
eventually just fucking died off.
And you've got a few fucking older firefighters with young guy haircuts and talk
about the glory days of September 11 you know,
they're like 50 now,
bro.
I was 40 I was just divorced.
Okay.
I'm just walking around everywhere I go and my fire hat on.
I didn't even bother to take it off.
They just dive in on my Dick,
you know.
Did they have a nine 11 firefighter calendar?
Like a sexy calendar?
Like they must've had to,
right?
Yeah,
they must have.
They had to write the gay community capitalizes on things like that with
children.
This is Tony Obey Unit Jean.
Yeah.
Did the,
the ego dissolving though is important?
I think you can,
well,
you know this,
but you can definitely engineer it.
Uh,
I've,
I've always,
once a year I do high dose of mushrooms,
Psilocybin as a reset.
So around my birthday at home with two or three of my closest friends,
we have always have a sitter.
We always have somebody who's smoking pot or otherwise semi coherent to watch
people make sure they can handle their weed too.
You know why he just,
yeah,
he popped by themselves freaking out.
You need a veteran.
Yeah.
No Paranoia and uh,
but that reset really I think strips away the superficial layers of manufactured
in need and so forth and allows you to look at problems that are very easy to,
easy to overcomplicate when you intellectualize things or rationalized.
So you accept whether it is a bad relationship or whatever it might be.
And the afterglow effect that I've felt a after each of these resets and each
one has been transformative and it's in solving one or two major problems in my
life is there's this afterglow effect,
uh,
after the effect of,
of supreme clarity in terms of your priorities and values for a few months.
For me,
it really lasts a long time.
I'm taking serious quantities,
but how many grams?
Uh,
I don't know the grams.
I've done it sort of eyeball portioning,
but I would say like a half a gallon.
Let's see what ziplock bags like gallons that,
right?
Like half of that.
Whoa.
That's a lot of fucking shrooms or are you getting really bad?
Sure.
I probably combination of two.
But I mean it's,
it's time travel.
You're not humble,
you don't function.
What do you think the way to that is?
Yes,
that sounds,
that sounds like a half ounce or,
I mean a friend of mine,
a friend of mine used to,
used to grow really extensively.
So we've never actually,
I've never seen him way anything I've just started with visual is tell you it
should weigh it.
You should weigh it so you know what you're doing.
I accidentally took a,
I think six or seven grams recently and it was the closest to death that I've
ever felt on mushrooms.
It was to the point where it felt like I was poisoned.
It don't where I'm puking
up.
How much do fuck with the isolation tank?
I have never been in an isolation tank.
I've been dying to do it.
I actually had a Charlie who works with me find locations in San Francisco and
this was a few months ago and then I had to take off for travel and wasn't able
to do it.
But I've been dying to do isolation tanks for a long time and uh,
wanted to have also,
I want it to do it extremely clear in terms of sobriety.
And then I want to try uh,
something with visual hallucinations in the isolation tank to see,
yeah,
get comfortable with the Tanja experience first.
Go sober for sure.
I always tell everybody if you can go sober,
unless you're a marijuana,
Jed,
I unless you just one of those dudes that gets high,
does everything and then my God,
go in there,
get in there.
It's not going to hurt you.
But if you're just like a regular dude who works a regular job and doesn't get
high all day every day and go sober,
I always say,
and then when,
when you do it,
you got to get comfortable with the experience to get good at it and by get good
at it,
there's a certain things in life to take a while to get used to it.
Like Jujitsu for example,
you know,
you're fucking getting in there and wrestling full blast with other grown men,
you're sweating each other's eyes.
Dudes will be on top of you and they'll armpit sweat would drip in your face and
you just deal with that because that's a part of Jujitsu and it's one of those
things where once you've been doing Jujitsu for 10 years,
when you get on the mat and you just,
you know,
you tap hands with people and you start sparring.
It's a normal thing because you're so used to this weird fucked up experience
and you put yourself in this sort of zen state.
Even though this is a bizarre experience for most people.
Yeah.
Well the tank and in that it's so alien that this,
this,
this time where your body doesn't move at all is so bizarre to you.
Like we're up.
We're constantly shifting our weight.
Even when we sleep,
we're moving around,
we're reacting to gravity were reacting to the pillow and our neck.
You know,
you're always,
there's,
there's input that's coming in.
It's the only time where there's no input.
It's so hard to just manage that.
It's so hard to just relax because you'll start coming up with fake things like
my ticket,
which is fucked,
which you'll start thinking like I'm just eating my Dick,
but then I'm going to get the salty water on my deck and then it's going to,
if some more and it takes a long time.
It takes a bunch of different uses to the,
you get to where like when I go in that thing,
that's my home man.
I'm so used to that thing.
I closed that door,
I lie back and I go,
let's find out what's up,
what's,
find out,
what's up,
what's,
see what's up.
And I never go in sober anymore.
I'm always blissed when I get in there because I just feel like marijuana,
especially high doses make you very,
very sensitive,
very sensitive and it makes you very,
uh,
you contemplate things you might not have contemplated.
My mind is always racing and a million different directions thinking about
things.
And there's nothing like the isolation tank to enhance that cause when you have
nothing coming in to your,
to your mind from the body,
the body is sending no signals.
Like all of a sudden you have radio silence and the mind is on its own.
He had the mind without any sensory input is fucking superpowered man in a way
that it's very difficult to describe because nobody ever experiences if this the
only environment like that in the world where there's nothing coming in and it
is beyond bizarre to me that more people aren't aware of this fucking thing.
I mean I taught,
I've been talking about it for years.
We put videos up about it and people come to me about it and they asked me like,
dude,
tell me about the isolation deck.
I'm like,
how could I possibly be an expert in this fucking thing?
All right.
All I am is just some dude who has one who uses it.
How are they're not scientists that are studying the benefits of this shit and
pushing it to everyone has stress relief as a clarity device,
as a device for objective reasoning and thinking and creativity.
Every artists should have won.
Every athlete should have won.
Every fighter should have one.
Anybody where you need deep,
intense thought without distraction,
you don't even fucking know what that is until you get in an isolation tank.
You got to get in there.
It's,
I've been pestering the shit out of you did to see it.
I've never achieved Ceylon.
You never seen him.
Well,
mine's different than anyone you've ever seen because mine is like a custom made
one by float labs.
There's one company in Venice that makes the very best in the world.
Their float labs.com no question about it.
They make the best equipment and the guy crash who builds it is a a freak.
He's a,
he's the mad scientist of isolation tanks.
He's actually come up with this new device.
You would love this guy.
He's right up your alley.
I want to introduce you guys to each other because he's so fucking nuts.
Super Genius,
brilliant but nuts.
And he's,
his latest thing is he's got this screen that he's developed for use above the
isolation tank and speakers that float in the water right next to your ear.
So you center yourself in between these two speakers and then the screen in
meds.
So little light that you cannot see the edges.
You cannot see anything except the image because you're in complete pitch
blackness when you're in that tank.
So anything,
you know,
his visual,
anything is visible.
So it's still the lowest amount of light physically possible for these things.
So literally the image is just floating in space in front of you would no other
distractions.
And apparently you can learn like a motherfucker.
This way you retain an incredible amount of information.
You,
you have all these,
uh,
the access to all this resources of your mind that are usually thinking about
like,
man,
my ass is fucking uncomfortable and should I take my wallet out of my back
pocket or these shoes suck.
And I got a,
of my sock all this information and keeps constantly coming into the mind about
just social things and noises.
There's none of that was none of that in there just as floating image.
So he's dedicated a considerable amount of time over the last three years.
He keeps talking to me about it.
I'm not interested in it because to me the,
what's the,
what's fascinating about the isolation tank is the quiet and solitude and I want
to go in.
I want,
I don't want to,
I don't want to see things right.
I want to go in,
I want to,
I want to explore the mind.
I want to explore a possible directions of consciousness.
Whether or not you can control that shit.
You know how much of your,
your,
your thought and how much of creativity
can control it.
That's all I'm concerned with.
That's why I like to use the thing,
but if you wanted to use it as an educational tool,
it would be fucking incredible.
It'd be great.
Have you played around with lucid dreaming at all?
This is a very interesting subject because we just started selling this stuff
called Alpha brain and what Alpha brain is,
it's a nootropic and it's basically a bunch of different naturally occurring
chemicals.
Things from plants and what have you,
and synthesize things that are supposed to enhance cognitive function.
So we put it out and it makes me feel clearer how much of that is a placebo
effect.
I'm more than willing to admit that.
I don't know,
because the placebo effect is an affinity,
phenomenal thing.
And on top of it,
it's,
it's been proven that the placebo effect actually can work even on people who
know it's a placebo,
you know?
So it's,
it's a very bizarre and misunderstood thing.
But the dreams lead me in my objective analysis of it to say there's something
very clear that's happening.
The dreams are much more vivid and they're lucid.
I'm having lucid dreams all the time.
And on top of that,
I remember a good deal of them when I wake up,
which is pretty rare,
you know,
I'm in the middle of dreams and I just stopped and I go,
Whoa,
I'm in the middle of a dream now.
And I'm not even close to waken up.
Like,
this is weird because a lot of times I'd be in the middle of a dream and go,
fucking,
this is amazing.
Oh my God,
I'm a dreaming.
Oh,
I'm awake.
I freak out that I'm dreaming and I just,
I blow the illusion away.
But with this stuff,
for whatever reason,
when I take this,
these Alpha brain pills,
especially at night,
I wake up while I'm having these lucid dreams and I'm able to stay in the dream.
I don't they say it's Coleen.
Do you know?
Yes.
The acetylcholine,
the neurotransmitter,
modern,
uh,
modern.
It's a lot of this and the,
I'm wondering if your product has huperzine a in it.
Who has seen a,
okay,
so [inaudible] is an Acetylcholine esterase inhibitor.
So the ace,
if you ever received one,
I'll show you what it is.
Yeah.
So the ace,
like Acetylcholine Esta race is something that breaks down acetylcholine.
So if it's an,
if it's a Acetylcholine esterase inhibitor,
it means that it allows you to call into,
lasts longer.
So it pretty much stays awake longer.
It's more,
it increases.
And I may get some of the technicalities wrong with the half life of
Acetylcholine.
So who present a is uh,
is,
is really fascinating for [inaudible].
Yeah,
sure.
So this is,
I can't read this should,
why?
Yeah,
this is challenged I font GPC calling.
Oh yeah.
Hooper,
Zia Serato.
So that's the 0.5% who present a that definitely will help vimpat vinpocetine
have been posted and also very cool.
Uh,
I used to have this in the product that I used to make back in the day.
We'll do take one of those and tell me what you think of it because,
uh,
I,
I Bobo a light me up giving it to my friends.
Every single one of them has had positive experiences with it.
I really do think it makes my mind seemed clearer with people who are interested
in,
we sell it@onatdotcomonnit.com.
We sold out of all of our orders in like the first couple of weeks of August.
It was cool.
We sort of underestimated
the amount of,
uh,
of demand for this stuff.
But it works.
I swear it works.
I,
I shit you not,
I wouldn't be talking about this.
And it's one of the,
you know,
like when I tell people if I'm selling something or if I'm promoting something,
I guarantee you 100% I believe it.
You might not agree with me.
You might say it doesn't work,
but I would never bullshit you never.
And this stuff to me,
I feel it does something to,
allows my mind to function at a smooth and energetic level.
It feels good.
Yeah.
The,
the ingredients makes sense.
I used to,
I got started with the smart drug stuff in college.
I decided to use the FDA personal importation policy to bring in,
uh,
Prasad Tam,
hider,
gene vasopressor on all of these drugs from Europe to test on myself
for learning purposes.
And one of them Vasopressin is used as an antidiuretic hormone and kids,
if they're older and they wet the bed,
they start using this nasal spray,
which is vast present.
What's fascinating about it is part of the reason,
if some people feel that they experience the same memory loss with alcohol,
they drink too much.
Is it depletes you of vasopressor,
which is necessary for short term memory,
some types of pot also.
Uh,
but if you,
if you,
Jack,
you know,
if you squirt and vasopressor and into each nostril wa I was able to do is
before Chinese character test,
we would have these character quizzes and I could literally take two shots.
One in each nostril,
flip through the characters sit to has a very short effect and then 10 minutes
later score 98 plus on these,
these recall tests.
Wild.
Really wild.
What is the shelf?
I mean,
what is the,
uh,
the act of life of it?
Yeah,
it's very,
very short.
Well,
the,
here's the thing with our,
uh,
yeah,
something like that I would guess,
but,
well actually it probably lasts longer,
but the learning effect that I experienced was very short.
It's like 30 minutes.
But since it's antidiuretic,
I mean it doesn't as a parent wouldn't,
didn't do very much good to have your kid not pissed for 30 minutes.
And then just what the bed,
so I'm imagining it last longer.
Uh,
but the,
the other one,
what is the,
what's going on though?
Why is it that allow you to
my,
my understanding may in somebody who's listening can probably do a better job on
Google of getting the,
getting the details of Wikipedia or wherever.
But vasopressin,
my understanding is that it is a hormone that is necessary for short term
memory.
So the actual formation of the short term memories,
which is all bio biologically limited.
Uh,
and I think we are very optimistic about how much we know about the brand.
I think that it's,
I mean [inaudible] have to rewrite it all in five years probably,
but most people think of short term,
you have working memory,
short term memory,
long term memory for that transfer to short term and longterm.
Once it makes that jump,
you're good to go.
So it's not like when I stopped using vasopressor and I lost those memories as
long as I repeated it used intelligent space repetition to repeat it at some
point before I lost it.
Uh,
with like the Ebbinghaus curve and all of that.
So,
uh,
Pimsleur,
if people are interested,
Pimsleur is the,
who looked very closely at this,
what's s spells a p.
I m s l e,
U R and they have a lot of language programs based on,
on his methodology.
I find it really slow.
I think they're faster ways to do it,
but the Vasopressin and then hydrogen I found to have a really favorable sort of
effect to side effect ratio.
Uh,
where's it been posting?
I didn't see anything from some of the really strong stuff like modafinil have
you see if you're at an Olympic Games.
I try that.
Vim proceed.
How do you say that?
Uh,
yeah.
Oh No,
there's,
there's uh,
yeah,
so I think this has been posted teen right here,
which is in the,
I've tried that on its own and I didn't,
didn't really feel anything with it.
You'll feel a lot if you,
and I don't recommend this,
but what it does is it sensitizes you to other things,
which is part of the reason why it makes sense to have in small doses and a
product like this,
which is why I'm not,
I'm happy to pop one of these,
but I'm going to wait about 30 minutes because I know that the blood caffeine
concentration I have right now,
if I combine it with simplicity and I'll be fucking ricocheting off the,
really give me that.
Let me try it.
See what happens.
That's,
so I wish,
I,
I wish I could be like you.
I wish I,
you seem like you have everything exactly planned out.
You know what,
this will happen to your body with your body that you know everything.
Brian,
listen,
I love you,
but you're a man child.
No,
but I mean most of the most fittest people in the smartest people aren't
connected to their body as much as you are.
I'm going to show you an experiment where I need some,
uh,
I'm going to need to grab some of your water then in that case.
Sure.
So I'll encourage everybody to listen carefully as my word per minute rate goes
through the roof.
Uh,
cool.
Thank you.
But powerful drugs,
smart drugs.
We have quite a quite a combination of things going on.
What?
Oh,
we do.
Yeah,
we got caffeine,
weed,
this stuff.
We've got a lot lot happening.
We're experimenting with the mind.
So what we add on at.com we just started putting this stuff out and uh,
the,
the positive feedback has been fucking crazy,
man.
People love this shit and I really,
you could have that male,
I'm not going to drink out of it now.
Nice guy.
Yeah,
you traveled all over the world.
Dude knows what kind of exotic shit you brought back with you.
How did you get into this?
A whole writing books and,
and,
and you know,
and breaking things down.
You have so many internet speeches and so many different,
I mean I saw a fascinating one that you did on dating that I thought was very
frank and honest and you know,
it was like you had a really great analysis and the analysis was that you don't
put all your eggs in one basket in your life.
You don't judge your own self worth by one singular thing.
And that's why you said you're invested in athletics and knowledge and
experience and you have a bunch of different things you're interested in.
So if something happens in some chance of fate,
one thing goes wrong.
You're not devastated,
you're still an accomplished human being and all these different areas.
But that so many people will get involved in relationships and from the get go
they would just grab one girl and just stick with this one.
And you were like date a few different women.
It seems so self evident.
It seems so obvious but date more than one woman until you find the one you'd
like the best.
If you stick with one like right off the bat.
Just because this was,
especially when you're first know each other and you're both completely full of
Shit,
you know what I mean?
Oh God.
Especially when you're young,
I mean,
what 24 year old is really that person when you first start dating them,
and especially guys were completely full of shit when we first started dating a
check.
We want them to like us,
we're on our best behavior,
and then we slowly let our real personality come out.
You know?
And I think you know,
your,
your advice was a,
was something that a lot of people wouldn't say because it makes you seem like
you're a player or it makes you seem like you're trying to be a sleazy guy and
you know,
look guys,
I'm going to show you how to get laid.
This is how it goes.
Number one,
who's going to do date other chicks?
Man,
what the fuck bro?
Why cut yourself short bro?
But you're saying exactly what that guy's saying,
but you're saying it and you've in a sense that you an intelligent way.
You've analyzed the situation.
He said,
well,
there's clear,
there's a clear way to eliminate a lot of the problems that people run into.
And this is one of them.
Yeah.
And it's,
uh,
for me,
I think that's part of the reason I get so much shit online too,
is that I,
I s if I have a strong opinion based on experiments or data or whatever,
I'll share it.
And then there's a lot that is then misconstrued from that.
Or maybe I just come across like a deck.
I don't know.
It could be that too.
But the way this all started was a,
I can help you there.
Okay.
You don't come across like a dick at all.
This is what you come across like you come across like a confident guy who's
smarter than me,
you know?
And when I hear a guy talk like that,
I'm like,
oh,
hey,
here's a guy that is well-read,
knows a bunch of different fucking languages,
thinks of things,
and then goes after them,
enjoys learning and information travels the world.
That makes me uncomfortable.
And then you say,
date a bunch of different women.
Oh you fucking piece of shit.
They're looking for something to be wrong with you.
That's what it is.
I mean,
I'm not blowing smoke up your ass.
You're a young,
smart guy with a lot of interest and that makes people upset.
And if you try to put logic and attach logic to anything that involves men and
women in relationships,
people will call you a piece of shit or chauvinist or you know,
or a player.
That's what it is,
guys trying to get laid.
What's the fuck what happened there and this and that when everybody's trying to
do,
isn't that why you're selling me fucking cars with no chicks in bikinis
straddled on the hood.
What?
What are you selling me here man,
you're selling me pussy.
And then if somebody actually likes pussy and they,
oh he goes after pussy.
What's he doing you fucking weak weak thing with your ego and no,
I think she's a hunt shit.
So you know Chinese fuck,
you know it says something about someone who's like out there just doing a bunch
of shit while you're sitting at home with a beer in your lab.
You know,
like this fucking queer know.
He just,
that's what it is.
That's hale.
Do anything wrong.
There's a big,
yeah,
there's a large contingent of people aren't convinced that I'm gay also.
Really?
I,
yeah,
yeah.
It goes both ways,
but the talk too smart.
You don't have enough flavor in your voice.
I masked it.
I'm from long island originally.
Man.
It takes a while.
Yeah.
You're smart guy.
You look,
here's the deal.
You might find a Boston accent.
I had a Boston accent for awhile.
I got rid of my Boston accent.
I had it.
When I listen to myself on TV when I was 19 years old,
I heard myself talking in an interview and I was like,
oh my God,
I sound like the biggest fucking Maura taekwondo tournament that I won.
And I was on TV.
And they're like,
yeah,
we've been working really hard.
Listen to me.
What is wrong with that?
You could shake that shit loose.
But you know,
we,
we obviously imitate our environment and your environment over the,
you know,
a big period of your life has been around thinkers and your environment has been
around people that are likeminded and in these subjects that you're pursuing.
That's why you sound like you gay.
Okay,
fair enough.
I think you sound like you sound like nobody.
They know.
See they don't know anybody like that.
It wouldn't know anybody.
Super Smart.
You know,
I've met a lot of mistakes and a couple of narrow areas and I think it,
that allows me to talk,
I use a lot of vocabulary and a few places,
but the,
the writing part was totally accidental.
Yeah.
I find writing really difficult.
I,
well this fucking books giant.
Yeah.
It's a big one.
It's like a chooser.
Our body has let latest one is your latest one.
This is a giant ass books on one.
Yeah.
That was after cutting 150 pages.
Tiffany Campbell.
Yeah.
There's like 600 fucking pages I promise myself
after,
uh,
after college because my senior thesis almost killed me.
I actually took a year off of school in large part because this project became
such a monster for me.
Uh,
and I promised myself that I would never write anything longer than an email
when I graduated.
And now he said that didn't work out very well.
But,
uh,
I knew I wanted to be a teacher because of a few people in my life who had
a huge impact on me,
like my wrestling coach,
uh,
Mr Buxton,
but a number of Reverend Greenleaf,
uh,
in a number of others and I just wanted to have that impact on other people,
but I felt like,
all right,
I'm going to have to go out in the real world,
actually do something and then I'll go back and teach.
Probably in ninth grade,
I think I to be really sensitive,
malleable time.
But when I stumbled across the writing stuff is because I was teaching a class
twice a year and one of the students in a feedback form said something along the
lines of,
I don't know why you're teaching 50 students in the class.
You just write a book and be done with it.
Like,
Hahaha.
And I started gathering these notes because I had terrible insomnia at the time
and I would wake up and I'm just write down whenever I was thinking to go back
to sleep,
it wasn't to keep the notes and these notes start piling up with sort of
hypothetical chapters and this,
that and the other thing.
And finally just asked a friend of mine who's a writer,
I was like,
what is this full of Shit?
Or should I actually go for this?
And he says,
yeah,
no,
you should go for it.
And he introduced me to four agents.
Three of them turned me down flat.
One was brand new but had a lot of experience publishing.
So he signed with me.
I use very early stage and then 26 publishers turned it down.
Then 27th one took it and then I was like,
Oh shit,
now I have to write a book.
And Wow.
Yeah,
initial print run was like 9,000 bucks or something like that.
It was this,
the premise behind your first book is the four hour workweek and what is the
premise?
The premise behind that.
I'd say it's two fold.
The first is that the deferred life plan I e or retirement based career planning
model is fundamentally flawed in a number of ways,
fatally flawed,
uh,
both,
both financially to sort of numerically and then also it's,
it's assuming you will live a long time,
which is I think of really foolish way to Spec out the next 2030 years of your
prime physical lifetime.
Second is that if you use a few approaches to analyzing your ideal lifestyle
that you're reserving for retirement and you actually arrive at a number like a
target monthly income to finance that whether it's the Aston Martin,
the fricking Chateau,
whatever the hell it might be,
that there are ways to analyze your work so you can get five to 10 x per hour
more done.
Whether you choose to then reduce your hours or just work the same number of
hours and just get 10 x the output.
There are things like Parkinson's law,
80 20 analysis that you can apply to your life just like you would apply it to a
company if you a CEO and you can jack up your productivity.
Uh,
that's the premise of the first button.
And so,
uh,
you know,
working with,
I'm involved a lot of startups in Silicon Valley and uh,
you know,
investor in Facebook and Twitter and stumble upon Evernote,
things like this.
And you see this type of split testing.
They do like testing two homepages and then they look at the numbers and then
they'll test two different buttons and then they'll look at the numbers.
And you can,
that led me to do that first with my own business,
which was in the sports nutrition world.
And then after to look at language the same way,
I'm like,
I'm going to test Pimsleur versus Michelle Thomas for two weeks and these are
the objective criteria I'm going to use to assess which is the better method.
And I just started applying that same type of split testing,
uh,
like the drugs.
Same deal.
I,
you know,
I'll tests,
I'll test to,
yesterday I was writing a book about a cooking and food right now and I'm trying
not to chop my fingers off.
So I actually bought a knife and a cutting board.
I'm traveling with it,
have it in my bag right now actually.
But,
uh,
and I was chopping and I separated like celery out into,
into equal lengths to test,
to Chinese method of chopping.
And then like a French method of shopping.
I just want to see which one was fastest.
And so like laid it out.
It's kind of weird,
but
you're a fucking Weirdo when you're measuring celery looking after the Chinese
method.
Just chop that shit up,
dude.
What are you doing?
That's ridiculous.
But you know what?
You never get to the mindset to write a book like the four hour work week unless
you have some sort of,
you know,
you can call it OCD,
but it's really just an exceptional interest in things.
And I owe that to my parents,
honestly,
but,
well,
my parents
never,
I came from very moderate background.
Both my parents work dual income family and uh,
they didn't have a lot of money for all sorts of trips and things like that.
But they would expose me to sorts of different
types of things like the aquarium or take me to the beach to let's say pickup
magnetic sand,
like the black sand with magnets and so forth.
And then when I have a younger brother and when one of us would become fixated
on something that we really were drawn to,
then my parents would just put everything behind it.
And so they didn't have a budget for him.
Bb guns out,
like a new bike out,
but they said we always have a budget for books.
And I remember I got really into fish and sharks more specifically.
So my mom bought me this really expensive book.
It's like $40 hardcover.
A Audubon society was Audubon society,
but it was fish and I took it to school and the teacher said to my mom,
at some point,
she's like,
you know,
you really shouldn't happen.
The have allowed him to bring the book to school,
he'll destroy the book.
And my mom was like,
he's not going to destroy them.
You're an idiot.
And a,
I think that by the,
the training of the conditioning that I've had through my,
uh,
through my parents to just go after whatever I'm interested in and feel
supported in doing that is what's led me to all this stuff.
Has it ever backfired when it comes to chicks?
If you ever become an unwanted stalker and didn't realize you were doing it,
you would just trying to be so persistent and shaky and that it became a
sickness.
Uh,
not,
not so much as a stalker.
The one habit I have,
which gets me into a lot of trouble with guys as much as,
as checks this might be also related to the gay thing is uh,
uh,
you know,
really it's sucking all the GAA cause it's a terrible habit.
And once you start,
I don't think it's like cigarettes,
but I would know what I was going to say is that that guy that can be edited
terribly.
But
I was a,
I look at,
I,
I'm fascinated by people and so I'll look at them.
And so I,
if I'm looking at Lucy and attractive girl across the bar and she's like smiling
and okay cool.
I go from like flirty,
I contact to creepy eye contact really quickly and it doesn't register with me
because I'm just fascinated at,
so you're a scientist and they think you're a killer.
They think I'm a serial killer.
Yeah,
but you're just a scientist.
I'm just fascinated by visual stimuli.
Need to sound like you're high when you're not high.
I might be kind of high when you're not high.
We're right now you oh,
you know what I mean?
It sounds like that's what a high person doll.
Absolutely.
And I mean I think that I could,
I mean I can get high.
I tried to engineer highs doing other things,
so I do,
I tend to do that say five to 10 minutes of Pasta and a meditation.
Just awareness meditation in the mornings.
And I always have either a poo,
air t,
which is a Chinese like dark tea or Yerba latte.
I really like Argentine.
Yerba Monte has three different stimulants in it.
So I tried to time it when I wake up so that it hits my bloodstream as I met as
a meditating.
Oh.
And uh,
it's not very strong,
but the after effect that I have for two or three hours is absolutely a high,
most of one of those guys that is really productive in the mornings.
Uh,
no,
not uh,
but I try,
I recognize from me at least that how I set up my morning,
the first 60 minutes
will determine my productivity for the rest of the day.
Now are you,
you're,
are you so organized that you have like every day lined up,
like you have objectives for each day and you have like a schedule for each day?
I have one or two pretty much work for yourself,
right?
Yeah.
I have one or two,
no more than one or two primary to dues per day and I actually try to calendar
as very as least as possible.
It's actually something I realized that Swartz Nagger does and a handful of
other people,
they will not put things on the calendar.
There's like,
call me if I'm available,
I'm available.
If I'm not,
I'm not.
And that provides,
at least me,
particularly if I'm writing on writing deadline with a lot of flexibility,
but I still have,
you know,
one or two to do's that I try to get done,
uh,
or may or hit a milestone in progress for uh,
before I check email.
So I try to set one hour in the morning to at least focus on one of those two.
Purdue's before any kind of reactive work.
You sound like such a,
I don't think I've ever met someone so productive.
Have you ever met anybody that even sounds
no,
but it's pretty awesome and like I'm spiker this book at how many interesting
things are in it?
Uh,
the Diet that you have in here,
that's the four hour body.
That's a difference.
The four hour body,
the diners is lose 20 pounds in 30 days.
And I was looking at through,
it's an all carb diet.
It's very weight watcher you almost like,
but kind of edits.
I lost a six 65 pounds in three months.
And when I did is I pretty much took a weight watchers and I cut out all the
bullshit.
So I just,
I didn't do like the fruits and,
and,
and I stay away from nuts and,
and things like that.
But it was pretty much I was getting the nutrients I needed and stuff.
But I it just more sought doing it like you missed foods but it just burned
calories.
The slow carb is actually closest to something I tried before arriving at that,
which was the cyclical ketogenic diet.
So Atkins has just a brand name applied to the Ketogenic Diet,
right,
where your body's working off of Ketones instead of glucose dangerous?
I don't think so.
No.
So what's dangerous is Keto acidosis that you see in Diabet,
like diabetics for example,
as opposed to ketosis.
But the diet was originally designed for epileptic children but should be put
kids on what people think of as an Atkins diet,
high,
high fat and then high protein and next to no carbs.
High fat is really important.
So you see a lot of cream in the diets for kids cut downs on it will cut down on
epilepsy,
epileptic seizures like 75 80% in many cases.
It's astonishing.
And the slow carb Diet,
cyclical ketogenic diet is where you combine it with exercise so that you're in
Ketosis for five or six days.
Then you carbohydrate load for 24 hours for the insulin and anabolic effects and
then you go back into ketosis.
Uh,
but it's a huge pain in the ass that one is.
But if you do roughly sort of a Paleo type diet with legumes and then you eat
whatever the fuck you off for one day,
it's like an approximated version of that.
That works really,
really well.
I don't think of a,
in terms of doing a B,
having a paleo diet,
but I try to cut back way back on my bread and is,
I try to eat very little of that stuff and I try to eat only shit the grows.
That's what I try to eat or treat it.
Anything that grows,
anything that's alive,
it's salads or vegetables or animals.
Anything that grows face or on the ground.
Yeah,
that's it.
That's,
that's what,
that's what I like to eat.
You know,
when you start eating a lot of pastas and breads and you know,
and sodas and,
and,
and just nonsense.
I absolutely feel a difference in how my body processes it.
What kind of energy my body has.
I always feel way healthiest when I'm just eating a lot of vegetables and just
meet and stuff along those lines,
which I guess is the Paleo Diet,
right?
It is.
I mean,
I think it's been that the term has been cooptive by a lot of people who turn it
into like a mania fad.
And I see you have a think on both extremes and not everyone who,
who had self identify with Paleo is extreme,
but you find that like the Paleo is in the vegans have this like extreme war
going on.
There's a war.
It's war of,
I'll take the Paleo,
I got five bucks on the Paleos.
Uh,
but,
but I think that we're a lot of,
a lot of folks miss the boat.
Uh,
and I think your approach is,
is right in the sense that when you become really militant about one side or the
other,
if your,
if your goal is to help other people,
you have to look at the compliance as much as how effective it is.
So it's like you might be able to get,
let's say someone on biggest loser and shaped by duct taping bowling balls to
their hands and having to run through the fucking desert with a weighted sled
behind them.
But once they're off of national television and they're not shamed into crying
with product placement,
like how long are they going to actually do that?
Probably never again cause that what they do on that show,
I saw a tweet at one point that I thought was great,
which was a biggest loser equals fat people crying and product placement,
which I though was really dead on because you can't fill an hour or whatever it
is,
half hour even on a weekly basis with simplicity,
you can't do it.
You can't be like,
all right,
Kettlebell swings three times a week.
You'd fucking done focus on your diet because that's the only way you're gonna
lose fat.
You can't do that because you have to fill 30 minutes of fat people running
around.
Um,
so I did actually see when,
where they had these morbidly obese people with weighted sleds attached to them
running through like sand dunes.
So terrible.
Yeah.
This is the doing yoga cruel and unusual punishment.
You know,
when you lose a lot of weight really fast,
it fucks your metabolism up to,
it doesn't,
especially when you do it at a really low calorie level,
if you like cut your calories,
like if you're supposed to have a thousand a day,
there's people that will go 500 a day just to lose weight quicker.
Yeah.
But when they do it,
Jack,
fuck yeah,
it'll kill your thyroid among other things.
And that's why you see women who've lost,
they lose 50 60 pounds when they do by starving themselves,
and then they really fuck their thyroid and they not only plateau,
but they start to have all sorts of hormonal issues.
And then they have empty tits as a Saturday when they're there,
when they're plump and their tits are big and full.
And then they get crazy and go anorexic and lose a ton of weight and their tests
become like empty little bags,
goats,
boobies.
It's the saddest thing.
Or when a girl is a perfect ass,
then she just gains
a little bit of weight and all of a sudden their stretch marks on her ass.
Like,
man,
what the fuck happened?
Like you didn't,
you weren't in a pain while your ass was growling.
You kept eating.
Like,
look what it did to your ass,
your ass as railroad tracks on it.
And you know,
at a nowhere,
what the fuck is that?
How do girls get stretch marks on the Ras?
So quick?
I saw guys get stretch marks on their packs,
I guess.
You know,
it's just like,
it's a lot easier to gain fat than it is to gain muscle.
So I'd like you see these guys with these incredible stretch marks on the
outside of the packs.
And I think that,
you know,
for women,
uh,
like guys put it on the Gut and women put it right on the ass and the legs.
Isn't it like genetic though as far as stretch marks?
Like some people just don't get straight like some women,
oh yeah.
Stretch.
But I think it has a lot.
I think that humidity actually plays a part too.
Yeah.
So the more humid the climate,
the frustration you're going to have,
but that totally makes sense.
Charles Poliquin who's,
uh,
Olympic level,
professional level strength coach recommends it.
His athletes or women who are losing a lot of weight or men I suppose for that
reason,
um,
use,
I think it's Gotu Kola as a cream,
which helps with the stretch marks.
Hmm.
Apparently that's what he prescribes.
Uh,
I use oil Valais Olay on of,
of,
so to answered my question,
you never get creepy with checks because you're obsessed with getting them.
I've been dating a great girl for about five months,
so I'm,
I'm not on the market,
but before that,
before that did you,
I'm not accusing you of anything.
I'm just saying that you have this incredibly inquisitive mind and this,
this,
I'm going to accomplish my goals mentality and there are certain people who have
that mentality and it works all great until it comes to people like you that
yeah.
Communicating with people because it to be super successful at a lot of things.
There's a certain amount of bull dog aggression or book,
you know,
the,
the ability to push forward and keep your eye on the prize and focus and focus.
And if you're a socially retarded person and you have that and you are into a
chick,
it could get ugly.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
I think that I've definitely creep girls out,
but it's usually,
it's usually because I'm doing some fucking experiment.
Like I remember one time I went,
I went on,
I went,
I went on this first date,
I was set up with gorgeous girl and showed up and then I was like,
don't let this weird you out.
And I pulled this electric scale out of my bag and started weighing all of the
pieces of food on the table.
And,
uh,
that was the beginning of the end.
Why didn't you do that?
Uh,
because I was trying to prove that the calories in calories out model as
cooptive by a nutritionist is totally inaccurate.
They don't understand thermodynamics.
So what I was doing is eating a seven,
I think it was 6.8 times my resting metabolic rate.
Like what you're supposed to eat,
need to maintain weight on a daily basis.
I ate seven times that in about 12 hours and to show that I could prevent myself
from getting fat even if I eat that way.
Uh,
so to clock in later with lower body fat like two days later.
And so I was weighing all my foods that I could do an accurate calorie count
later.
So if I had whatever amount of cheese,
I want to know how many grams that was.
So later I can do the multiplication and do all the adding.
So you,
your contention is that it's based on a,
a weight to energy to what like I don't know.
Oh No,
no.
So it is,
what were they wrong about?
What they're wrong about is they'll say,
all right,
you have calories and eating and then you have calories out exercise.
So that's your balance.
In reality,
there are many different ways you can get rid of calories besides extra stress,
stress,
heat.
So if you put yourself in cold,
so,
uh,
Ray,
who was the,
one of the NASA scientists and the book,
he tripled his fat loss by using color treatments where they're like a cold
showers or ice baths,
tripled his rate of fat loss.
I mean that's the,
that's the equivalent of taking like methamphetamine
jasmine and when and how do you do that?
What do you do?
You just getting a cold shower every day.
Blues.
Yeah.
How about how long have you got to be in that show?
I do like the few minutes.
I mean very short and I actually have it makes you lose fat.
I prefer,
it triggers a hormone that I think people are going to hear it a lot more about
in the next few years.
Probably the next one or two years.
Adiponectin,
most people have never heard of this improves,
uh,
among other insulin sensitivity.
But also the rate of fat loss and when you,
and cold triggers,
this also triggers a Luton Ising hormone,
which you of course seeing your blood panel when you do a testing looking at
testosterone,
which I think is the primary driver behind sex drive.
So if you're able to jack up your LH,
you,
you're like,
you want to go hump a corner,
it's really pretty,
it's pretty awesome.
But the cold showers make you horny.
Uh,
you have to take it like an opposite of what they always told us.
Well,
it'll definitely make you look like less of a Ron Jeremy,
but if an ice bath,
but the,
the intermediate and a longer term effects.
Yeah.
Higher sex drive.
Absolutely.
That's incredible.
Because that's what they always say,
right?
Take a cold shower and it cools you off your horn.
Yeah.
But in fact,
it just makes you harder.
It'll make you,
yeah.
You'll need some recovery time for taking ice baths.
I like an ice bath up to like mid chest.
Okay.
So when you,
uh,
when you,
you need 120 pounds of ice,
how much recovery time do you need before you're ready to rock?
A 20 minutes,
20 minutes,
right.
Do you have to get in any warm water to rejuvenate or,
I would take a hot shower afterwards.
I would actually take a hot shower beforehand.
Uh,
so there's something called contrast therapy that the east Germans used to use
where you take a,
for example,
hot,
a very hot shower so that the blood vessels dilate,
uh,
in an area,
this is after sports.
So I started using this for sports stuff.
I've all sorts of back in.
So I do hot on the back and then go right into the ice bath.
And then that way,
like hyper constricted and then you get out and you do the,
you do the hot shower to finish and that's supposed to help flush out debris and
a damaged tissue and so forth really works.
It's amazing.
It's like,
it's like an extra two days of recovery and
cold therapy.
And they used to do that back,
uh,
for injuries on a long time ago.
In the,
in the 80s.
I tore my Sartorius muscle.
Yeah.
There was a big one too because this is,
uh,
I was uh,
this was the third year that I was defending the state championship.
Yeah.
And Taekwondo and I couldn't do any sparring.
I couldn't kick the bag.
I used to have the only,
the only thing I can do is throw kicks in a swimming pool and a,
I had a bunch of different therapies to,
to fix that.
And one of the big ones was getting a hot,
hot,
hot bath and then plunge right into a bath full of ice cubes.
Yeah.
It was crazy.
Sartorius.
Yeah.
Early.
It was bad.
It was a bad tear.
It went right up to the hip.
Yeah.
You know,
you're doing taekwondo,
you're whipping your legs around his crazy,
unnatural motions with all this torque.
There's amazing amount of Torque,
especially.
You get really good and really flexible.
And then you know,
I was really young too.
When your body,
when you're like 1718 years old,
it just has some elasticy to it at springs and whips,
you know,
so you generate so much force you can rip things apart.
Tore my ACL,
tore my sartorial rip rib cartilage.
No I haven't turned my eyes for tore his hamstring as the worst leg.
Muscular done connective tissue issues that I've had.
I did it once so bad.
My whole leg was black and blue.
I just hopped and then the rest of my leg,
like from my balls all the way down to like below my knee was total black and
blue like I got shot.
That's terrible.
They're saying this guy,
I know he lives actually around here,
Scott Mendelson,
he's broken nine records in the bench press world records like I can bench about
1200 pounds of Macedonian and I've seen him do warm ups with five plates on
either side just like somebody would use an empty bar.
And he,
he's a huge guy.
No big surprise there and it's like three.
The last time I saw him,
he was three 20 and had a six back to give you an idea.
Uh,
but when,
uh,
people don't realize when you start handling those types of weights,
you're using your legs in a major way,
even for the bench press.
And so I remember seeing him at one point and he was hobbling around.
He showed me his leg,
his entire,
he tore his entire quad,
which is like the size,
it's like twice the size of my torso,
uh,
doing the bench press.
So his entire quad was ripped off of his,
yeah,
it was just completely black.
It looks like,
I'm sure what you're like look like.
Yeah.
Muscle tears are a mother fucker,
man.
It took a long time.
I do.
Yeah.
I'm so careful as I get older about warming up and you know,
and getting really loose before I do any of that,
that has helped me so much,
man.
Yeah.
If you're done any in any of the rolling like lacrosse balls or from a
footballer's,
those are great.
I find that there's a deep tissue.
God,
I go to the fucking hurts like hell man.
And it's a dude,
which is uncomfortable cause I always used to go and get deep tissue massages
from checks.
But then I started getting real sports massages from someone who's a,
who was a strength coach at Purdue and like he's legit.
He breaks your shit down dude.
It's fucking painful.
You know,
he has all these emotion things.
He does too.
He stretches you in all different range of motions while he's like just dig and
elbows into the muscle.
It's fucking,
you want to tap out left and right.
It's,
it gets pretty.
Sounds like art.
It has even ever mentioned that is fucking painful.
Yeah,
it's painful but it's fucking amazing.
It allows you to go back to training like much quicker.
You know,
there's all sorts of different things that we don't like to do that are
uncomfortable like the ice bass and like this kind of shit.
But God,
when you do do them,
it's so important.
He a big difference.
You
other thing I've found to help a lot with muscle muscular injuries is either
Arnica or this is a,
and this is an actual,
is that topical ethics stuff aren't,
so the Arnica can be,
it can be homeopathic.
What I prefer the,
the,
I have a lot of issues with most of homeopathy,
but the trauma is a product that you can get at a whole foods and it's t r a u m
e l and it is astonishing effective.
I don't know exactly the mechanism of action,
but it really works really like muscular Musculo a connective issues.
Oh it's fantastic.
Like helps healing.
Yeah.
Like the speed of healing.
So how do you spell this stuff sort of for people out there,
t r a u m e l and you can get both ingestible and topical if you have a serious,
if I have an acute injury,
I had one recently,
a few months ago in the hamstring,
went immediately to whole foods,
got a bunch of bags of ice for an ice bath and bought a bunch of trauma and like
high dose vitamin C and a few other things too.
Immediately sort of tried to address the short term inflammation because I was
at a certification for crossfit endurance and had to do,
I had to do the second session the next day and I wanted to do the session the
next day.
How did you do it with a blown hamstring?
Uh,
it was like a partial strain,
I would say.
Uh,
was certainly wasn't any type of,
of of severe tear,
but it was enough that I was hobbling around after a few hours and you know,
if you feel it that day,
you know what I mean?
Like you're really gonna feel it the next day.
Uh,
but it worked with the ice trommel contrast therapy and uh,
I was,
was able to go to the next day.
I wasn't 100%,
but I was able to actually do a running sir.
Well you must not have been that big of an injury cause I've got to assume that
that's,
that would fuck you up for quite a while if it really was.
I mean there's nothing that was going to make you heal overnight,
right?
No,
no,
not,
not overnight.
I think that stuff you believe
what you can do it,
it does help longterm.
In this particular case,
my concern was just addressing the inflammation and stiffness so I could train
the next day.
The following week.
Yeah.
I was a mess because I took an injury and then built on top of it.
Oh,
so it became worse.
Yeah,
but in this,
in that case,
I was willing to do it because I just wanted to finish the cert and I was in
Colorado,
so
it's amazing how much we know about fixing the body though,
man.
I mean,
I have both of my knees had been reconstructed ACL reconstruction.
It's,
it's amazing that,
you know,
if we live just one lifetime earlier,
I'd be a criminal or it shouldn't,
you know,
people don't like that.
They think that's an offensive term.
I would have be a person who is both knees are fucked up.
How about that?
Now there would be no,
meanwhile they work a hundred percent they work great.
Yeah,
no problems.
Kick boxing,
Jiu Jitsu,
everything works great.
And just fix it.
Put it back together again.
Yeah,
it is wild.
It's incredible.
It's amazing when you think about it.
I think,
oh no,
I was just going to say that.
Uh,
for people who we really want to take the,
the regenerative stuff seriously,
what I would encourage people to start researching is looking at banking stem
cells.
So getting stem cells at a younger age to bank so that you can use them later if
you want to get like a,
a,
what does the term I'm looking for?
It's not mesenchymal.
Uh,
Polly,
Paula plurry potential stem cell.
So you bank the stem cells that are like your younger stem cells and then later
on if you need a liver or you needed this,
you needed that to ensure that you don't get rejection.
You can actually take that stem cells differentiated into what you need and then
grow it.
Have you done that?
Uh,
I am in the process of trying to do as it expensive.
Is it?
I don't think it needs to be expensive because there are some doctors who are
trying to get different,
I believe so cells that you can differentiate from skin as opposed to having to
take it out of,
let's say bone marrow.
I was willing to do bone marrow,
so I was going to,
I was actually going to do bone marrow harvesting.
Oh my God.
Drilling through the hip.
That must be painful.
It's not fun.
That's not fun.
How long are you out for when you do something like that?
I don't know.
I haven't done it.
Uh,
but I was going to do that and then one of my buddies who actually designed a
device for that,
I was like,
well,
maybe want to consider looking at skin or blood or something like that.
And I was like,
all right.
Yeah,
I'm happy to store whatever I can,
but wow.
Yeah,
good idea actually.
it's wild stuff,
man.
I do think that the life extension folks who take,
you know,
200,
300 pills a day,
I think they're making a sort of,
I think they're setting themselves up for a fast in bargain because your liver
talking about the liver does not handle 200 pills a day.
Very well.
I mean it's uh,
that's part of their vitamins you think are bad for breaking down for your
liver?
Uh,
it depends on the vitamins.
Yeah,
I would say,
I mean I tried to get everything I can through whole foods,
which is a very new thing for me because few years ago I was like,
blood test,
identify problem,
sniper shot with a pill fixed or injection fixed.
And what I've realized when you start looking at,
uh,
that the history of,
of uh,
let's say Beta carotene,
so it was found to be good for world.
He was thought to be very good for eyesight among other things.
So people start taking isolated Beta carotene,
which then caused a lot of problems.
So I'm trying to get whatever I might be deficient in.
Let's say I found out that I was deficient in selenium.
You did a test called spectracell.
You can go just about anywhere in a hundred bucks you're done,
and I found out as deficient salinium fixed that doubled my sperm count and
tripled my testosterone by addressing a selenium deficient
double your sperm count.
You shouldn't loads in the cups on a regular basis until as your loads.
Yeah,
I was really in that too.
Yeah.
Also,
probably not good first day conversation,
just from experience.
Did you bring that up the same date when you're measuring the a different is a
different date in their life.
They were like,
so what are you up to?
And I was like,
man,
I'm doing some experiments.
Like what kind of experiments?
I was like,
well,
let me tell you.
And then yeah,
I find that you can't even bring up your loads of girls.
Ashley been around them once.
Once you've had sex and they had been around your loads,
then you're allowed to bring up your loads,
but until that moment loads are off the table,
it's you don't get promoted.
It's like if you're talking to a girl on a first date and she starts talking
about her yeast infection issues.
Yeah.
What buzz?
What is this
nonsense?
Fairy tale.
Kill the bitch.
Oh Man.
Find out what that problem was by the way.
It's squirting.
Oh,
with your girl and why don't you explain to the whole world g spot stimulation.
Yeah.
Okay.
She's peeing on you bro.
[inaudible] you got an issue with his girl p and all over the place just
started.
It is g spot.
Orgasm is,
I think is what you just rock.
You're just killing it down hard.
That's what it is.
The doctor said that because the doctor's not there when the piss comes out,
the dog doesn't know what the fuck is talking about.
Doctor needs to shut his mouth.
He's just trying to make you feel better.
God,
I had one buddy,
there's a close friend of mine and he,
he called me at like four in the morning at one point,
uh,
traumatized because this girl,
he was really into head.
It's actually the first time and she was,
she was riding in Calgary and then she's,
she's about to come jumps up like,
like post on his chest and jumps up to her feet and then like score,
it's all over his chest and he was,
so he was really into her.
This is the first time they had sex and he was just so traumatized by this like
power role reversal.
He was,
uh,
he was really like beyond constellation,
but he called me a four in the morning and start sending me text and they were
just incomprehensible.
So do it on his chest on purpose.
Like,
like a god coming on a girl's Ted's,
I mean,
I can't imagine why else you would like prop yourself up to the sumo squat and
do that.
It's awesome.
Yeah,
it seems like a very aggressive,
so that's a very aggressive like alpha dog move.
Exactly.
It's like an animal.
I think that if some girl did that first time she had sex,
that's insane.
But meanwhile,
dudes do that all the time when we come on your kids or somehow that's
acceptable.
Why is that acceptable?
It seems like it is though.
It seems like it is acceptable for guy to come on a girl's Ted's,
but it's not acceptable for a girl to fucking piss all over your chest.
I wouldn't know what that girl looks like.
Just sounds so advertising.
I don't know why we have so much resistance.
Yeah,
I don't know what it,
but you know,
loads wire girls.
Why they allow that?
Why don't some of them actually like it?
That's ridiculous.
It's the most ridiculous shit ever.
Like loads all over you protein.
It has nothing to do with protein.
It's just dirtiness.
That's what it is.
Being bludgeoned by porn.
It's just sheer.
It's good for your skin.
That's got to have a boat.
Shar,
do you,
do you look at porn?
Does that have a bizarre,
I mean I,
I have,
uh,
I,
I'm not nearly as organized as you are,
as analytical as you are,
I don't think.
But I have this thing about porn and the,
the big thing that I have is that I know that this only happens when someone
abuses someone.
It just,
it might happen with guys,
but with girls,
it only,
they only do that.
They only let guys fuck,
I'm on camera because something happened at an early age.
It's almost like unanimous.
It's almost like 100% of them have been molested.
Some,
it bothers me,
you know,
and even though they're having a great time and even though they're hot and
maybe they love Sax and maybe it is fun for them,
maybe they do enjoy it.
I can't not do the math,
you know,
I can't,
you know.
So when you being this analytical guy,
how do you look at stuff like that?
How do you look at like Internet porn and things along those names?
Yeah,
it's,
you know,
I,
it's,
it's a tricky,
it is tricky.
Like to look at it,
I have no,
uh,
yeah,
I don't have like a strong moral stance against Portma.
It's hard not to think of the backstory,
particularly if you actually see any type of documentary or any type of coverage
or this,
you know,
adult film or pornography.
You do see the patterns really clearly.
Uh,
but she,
this,
I mean,
just as a,
you know,
a healthy male.
It's,
it's tough.
I just,
I know you're right.
You're right.
It's still with his father.
I talked,
I remember talking to think about it.
I talked to one of these tech guys who worked with anchor free I think was if
they have a program called the hotspot shield,
which is great if you're traveling,
for example,
if you go to China it won't work.
But if you go to some countries where they blocked Pandora or youtube,
you can use hotspot shield and it,
it,
uh,
it allows you to,
to get around that really like if you're in like Dubai and it gives you a
tunnel.
Exactly.
So it's fuck as he bring up Dubai,
I asked him who most of his users were and he said people in the Middle East
watching porn,
it was like,
this is called again,
what's it called?
It's called a hotspot shield.
And how do you get,
is it a software?
It's free software program.
You can download it.
It works.
Yeah,
it works.
So it's,
it's Kinda like tour in the sense that if you're trying to route,
you know,
like in Iran or other places where people are trying to route out or route,
can they lock you in jail forever if they catch you with this?
Probably.
Oh,
I don't think so.
I mean,
as,
as a visitor for example,
when I was in Turkey and I wanted to watch stuff on,
I think it was youtube or was Pandora one of the two.
And I got really irritated that I couldn't access one of the other and I just
use hotspot shield and it was problems with this work with people who if they
work
in an office and the office block certain things,
could they put this on their computer?
Uh,
if,
if the,
if the it is set up so that they can install and download,
yeah,
they should be able to,
oh shit,
bitches.
I just found a solution to your problems.
Your boss was sleeping.
Feel free to walk off in new cubicle.
Now,
MSNBC Guy Hacked yesterday by the hackers and they did a fake terrorist,
uh,
thing on Twitter.
This,
somebody hacked MSNBC and was just like,
oh my God,
you know,
there's a terrorist shit going on at Ground Zero in New York City and like did
all this shit and it's fucked up.
Yeah.
And then,
uh,
somebody uh,
announced yesterday that Steve Jobs died that's connected to some kind of news
publication,
but then they deleted it immediately and they said,
sorry,
we got our facts wrong or something.
But thinking that,
so someone's hacking newspapers now.
Yeah.
Either that or someone at that particular newspaper is shorting apple.
Right.
Just trying to set up,
just trying to tee it up for a nice double,
oh,
sorry guys,
we've got our facts wrong,
but thanks for selling all your apple,
android,
z.
Would
that to be right?
That would be pretty easy to do at this point in time.
People just waiting for the,
the story of jobs being dead.
Did you see the photo of him where he's kind of wearing this black dress looking
thing?
It looks like he weighs like 90 pounds.
Yeah.
Everyone at the apple store is like,
ah,
that's,
that's Photoshop.
That's not,
that's not real.
Like they're defending his boss,
like King Bee.
What is it guy like that there's a,
there's clear evidence that no matter how much money you have,
either is only a certain amount and you can do for your health.
Yeah.
You know,
there's only a certain amount do you attribute when you see a guy that's got
like,
that's sick like that and um,
I've talked before about a girlfriend that I had to go to a great boss.
He was a really nice guy who had massive cancer at 50.
It was dead like that.
Yeah.
And it was a guy who worked,
he worked for a studio and he had an incredibly stressful job to his constant
every day,
six,
seven days a week,
all day long.
He made a good living because of it.
But the guy just lived in a hurricane,
you know.
Do you think that that has a direct result on,
on physical health?
I think it has to,
uh,
because elevated cortisol,
you have interrupted sleep.
Uh,
I think it has to have a direct impact on,
on just about everything.
Uh,
this part of the problem with looking at studies that try to look at or disprove
the correlation between stress and cancers that a lot of these people define
stress differently.
Um,
but I would think that in addition to those types of stresses,
which are definitely biochemical events,
uh,
carbohydrate intake,
so there's a great book called good calories,
bad calories,
and there's,
uh,
there's one section on disease states and carbohydrates.
And I think that if you remove gluten,
grains,
et Cetera,
it's very hard for certain types of cancers to grow a really.
Yeah.
And one,
I remember at one point,
one of my close friends,
young woman,
uh,
was,
had been diagnosed with,
I think it was cervical cancer and spoke with his doctor percent at a Ted,
uh,
William Li,
l I,
and he actually has a white and green tea blend that selectively inhibits blood
cell growth in cancer tissue.
How cool is that?
So,
yeah,
obviously if the cancer can't get nutrients,
can't get blood than it,
it dies.
And so I've been,
uh,
I consume that ti as a preventative measure and also obviously cut out the
refined carbohydrates six days a week.
And then I go ballistic
there.
We gave a cheat day,
nice ice cream,
whatever the fuck you,
whatever on whatever I want.
That's a smart move.
You know,
my friend Eddie was doing that.
Eddie Bravo was all Atkins diet.
He would be Atkins all week.
And then on the weekends he would start off,
it started off with just Sunday,
but then it became Saturday,
Sunday,
and then it was Friday after midnight and now he weighs 400 pounds.
He's fit,
he takes care of himself.
But it was hilarious being around them on Sunday because Sunday go off like a
rocket.
Is that what you do?
Do you eat like donuts and shit or,
well,
what I find is that I encourage people,
particularly when they're getting started to just go crazy and after two,
three
or four weeks and making themselves sick,
second,
they start cutting back.
They start chilling out.
Uh,
and they'll still have fun.
Like when I have my cheat days,
I mean I'm having chocolate croissants,
I'm also having some good food during the day,
but then I'll have,
you know,
wild nettle pizza with an egg on top of whatever.
It's great stuff,
but I don't strive to make myself sick anymore.
It's not a point.
It's not like I want to reach that threshold where I used to just,
it was like,
oh,
I wonder how many boxes of donuts I can eat.
It's fucking cheat day and uh,
you get,
you get past that point pretty quickly.
But for people who are very phobic of diets of any type,
it's really helpful in the beginning stages to allow them that psychological
release valve.
What it also does,
we were talking about thyroid is when you selectively overfeed like that,
you can actually improve conversion of t four to t three active thyroid so that
you actually find that people lose more weight over time when they have that
overfeeding once a week.
It was pretty cool.
Really.
Yeah.
Also affects Leptin,
like recalibration.
Well,
you lose more weight by being a pig.
Yeah.
By being in one day a week just being a savage.
Why would that be that your,
your body just realizes that it has to kind of deal with that every now and
again and so it just ramps everything up.
Yeah.
What it doesn't do it I think partially is it doesn't downshift because it
believes that it's in a starvation mode or that some type of food category is
in,
in famine essentially.
So I think that when you,
when you overfeed the mechanism isn't entirely clear,
but there have been a lot of studies looking at this where if you,
you,
you calorie load that one day it has an effect on everything from Leptin to
thyroid to just about everything else.
It's cool.
Antibiotic positive.
Oh yeah.
Very positive effects on that.
So it's good to be a pig one day a week,
one day a week now it's amazing.
Yeah.
If you're an athlete you would end up doing it with other types of foods.
So you'd use like a keen while or yams,
root vegetables,
things like that to jack up your calories if you don't want to do the donuts.
And all that shit.
Cause if you don't want to cheat,
yeah cause if you want to carve up properly,
like having a lot of fructose and table sugar is half fructose,
right?
The sugar that's in and fruits,
it fucks up your car bloat terribly.
So if you're actually training like your GSP and you want to fuck with Carbo
load,
whatever,
after when then you don't want to be getting like table sugar is a terrible
choice.
Right?
So you'd want to avoid that.
But I like the chocolate croissants.
So that's table sugar though,
right?
Oh yeah.
Lots of convection or sugars,
sucrose,
fruit sugar won't have the same issues like fruit,
sugar,
Google will mess up your,
your,
your carb up.
So you want to avoid that tip you want to avoid for other,
so when you carve up,
it's all just breads and pastas and you'd be focusing on a lot of that.
Or if you wanted to get really fancy with it,
you'd use something like waxy maize starch or some type of actual supplement.
There are guys who do that.
There's a really good product called waxy maize.
Say that waxy maize starch,
there's a product issue.
Eat it.
Yeah.
You could convert it into a powder and you eat it just like you would a protein
powder.
Um,
yeah.
You drink it in.
Exactly.
And what is the benefit of this starch?
It has a,
uh,
you avoid some of the side effects of let's say,
consuming something that's too rapidly digested like glucose where you're just
basically injecting yourself with Gatorade.
Yeah,
Gatorade would have,
I'd have to look at it.
It's going to have probably some glucose,
but also it probably has sucrose gross in it.
Um,
but what I used to do when I was getting really crazy about the CKD,
the cyclical ketogenic diet is that I wouldn't say that again,
see the cyclical ketogenic diet.
When I was doing that,
when I started my carb up day,
I would start with glucose tablets,
which are disgusting.
Oh,
I would,
I would start with the fastest and then move out to the slowest that more slowly
digested.
So I didn't use waxy maize,
but I would start with Lucas Tablas.
Then I would move to some type of more rapidly digest.
Let's say white rice,
and then I would go into other grains and slowly move out to the,
the longer digested carbohydrates and then also start infusing a protein because
the carb up can be helped with protein depending on the ratio.
This is MMA.
MMA teams need a dude like you on hand to tell him how to fuck a carb up and had
to eat before a fight.
Yeah,
I can help them with that.
Why don't you write a book on that Shit,
man.
I,
uh,
you know,
it's,
uh,
I've been quite frankly because it's just not much of a market for it,
but I have,
I've done some fun stuff with some NFL Lineman as well as I've worked with a
couple of fighters,
uh,
just on the cutting weight stuff.
Not so much the carbing up,
but like cutting for weight classes.
So dangerous.
Yeah,
it's real.
I used to cut 20 plus pounds twice a week in high school for rest.
Oh my God.
It's really dangerous and stunt your growth.
I don't think it's stunts my growth.
I think it fucked up my,
uh,
I think it's screwed up my,
some of Mike,
my feedback loops in the body.
Absolutely.
Uh,
because I mean I had a resting pulse when I wanted,
when I had to go to sleep and I would assume that I would lose it,
say half a pound to Penn and a half just over,
over the evening,
over the sleep on my resting pulse was like one 20 plus.
I mean it's like one 40,
it was just laying in bed trying to go to sleep and my blood is like ketchup,
so it's just like [inaudible] is horrible,
horrible.
It's so bad for you.
And that year,
I remember that year there were a couple of wrestlers who had a organ failures
because of dehydration and at that point they then changed the rules.
I don't know what they are now.
Where you,
you weighed in as you went onto the mat.
So you actually weighed in right before your wrestled,
so you disincentivized from cutting too much water because you'll obviously,
yeah,
they do that at the Monday owls,
the Jujitsu championships,
and a lot of people believe in that.
They think that the way MMA fighters do it is ridiculous and dangerous that they
weigh in,
you know,
the day before,
20 hours,
24 hours,
and they gained oftentimes 10 1520 pounds depending on the guy,
you know,
six,
seven,
eight bags of IV drips,
constantly drinking pedialyte and electrolyte replenishers and it's intense.
Fucking scary.
The load that puts on the body though and the thing that you're going to throw
that same body in the combat 24 hours later,
you know,
power lifters are the same way.
Oh yeah.
They cut
crazy amounts of weight.
They're strong for their weight class.
Did they cut weight and then did they have time after they weigh in before they
regenerate?
It's generating,
it's like the,
it's like the same type of time and yeah,
it's not much.
I mean you have 24 36 hours maybe.
Oh,
you do have 24 hours.
You might have 24.
That's crazy.
They should weigh a man right before they live.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
Because these guys,
I mean they're doing the same thing.
They're doing like Celine bag drips with electrolytes and so forth.
You see a lot of people do it the wrong way and they end up losing because
they'll try to rehydrate and they won't take into account the electrolytes or
they won't take into account that you're,
you're like gastrointestinal track is not designed to handle six gallons a PDL.
Yeah,
no shit.
And so they just get this horrific diarrhea,
which of course compounds the problem and then they get ruined when they,
when they got to fight.
Uh,
so yeah,
if you're going to lose weight like that,
you have to use,
if you're going to use any diuretics,
potassium sparing diuretics,
you also see guys cramp up really badly because they don't have enough
potassium.
Anyway,
I could go on and on about this,
but yeah,
it's a,
the cutting weight's really bad for you,
which were one of the most dangerous things,
at least in wrestling.
There's not head trauma.
And one of the things they've shown in boxers that the deaths in ring deaths,
almost all of them have been men cutting weight.
Yeah.
The lower weight classes is where it's an issue.
And the heavyweight classes of course,
you know,
there's still instances of brain damage and you know,
pugilistic good dementia or whatever they call it.
You know,
when you see guys like Joe Lewis and,
or Joe Frazier rather who could,
you know,
his,
his speech is clearly affected,
uh,
of being punched in the head that's still exists,
but no deaths.
The deaths like the Duck Kook hymns and you know,
the,
all the uh,
in ring desk to the really bad injuries like Gerald McClellan,
Gerald McClellan was a famous wait cutter.
He cut a lot of weight and in this fight with Nigel Benn,
he had a cerebral hemorrhage and wound up being severely disabled.
He's blind now and mostly deaf and barely remembers his past.
And it's weight cutting mat.
Horrible.
Yeah,
it's weight cutting.
I think another reason,
at least this is,
and trauma of course,
it's something I've thought about is that the lighter weights too,
you see these guys mean they'll take 12 rounds of headshots.
Yup.
And there has to,
I mean,
I'm just thinking that there has to be a cumulative effect of the cerebral edema
and the swelling that perhaps you just don't get if you're a heavyweight and you
get hit once and you just fill out like a light.
I don't know.
It's any head trauma.
Rihanna,
they're finding soccer players have serious issues and they're telling kids not
to head the ball anymore.
They're finding a lot of soccer players actually you become sick with Lou
Gehrig's disease.
You have,
uh,
issues with,
they're all sorts of,
I mean they basically have the same issues that boxers have cause a good head.
You know,
when you hit a ball that's coming at you really hard and you catch with your
head,
that's like getting slapped with a jab.
It's not a lot.
I mean they,
they're fine.
They're not pussies.
So they just run it off after they got hit in the head.
But that soccer ball,
but the reality is every time you get up pop,
every little pop is bad.
You know you can,
you're practicing on the field
and you're kicking the ball and heading it at each other back and forth and
you'll realize it.
But you're getting jabbed in the face.
We are just now coming to terms with how dangerous head trauma is.
You know they're there.
That's something that would be fascinating,
but that's exactly how the plant of the apes got started.
They wanted to fix people's brains and then they fucking used it on monkeys.
The monkeys could smarter than people.
So that could be an issue of how to be careful.
You got to come their thumbs,
man,
we've got to figure out how to,
how to make grains rich.
You can rejuvenate brain tissue and re rehabilitate brain trauma.
That would be amazing.
Then people could fight and never even worry about it.
You know,
they just fix your brain after done church charge it back up.
Cause right now,
man,
like you've,
you've,
you've been aware of those NFL players that they've done autopsies on them and
found that of their 40 year old men and they have the brain of an 80 year old
Alzheimer's patient.
It's horrible.
That's not good.
Yeah.
I mean they get Alzheimer's,
you get so many different diseases,
Lou Gehrig's disease,
so many different trauma related ailments.
Meanwhile,
football's awesome.
So how do we fix that science step in?
I don't like seeing fighters get brain down as it kills me.
It drives me nuts.
And I've seen guys,
you know,
we were talking before the show about,
uh,
oh yeah.
You know,
what if there's more that
you can kill it with.
I was just saying,
you know,
even watching some of the recreational MMA guys,
if they do it for long enough and they're training with guys who are hitting
them a lot,
thank you.
Uh,
you can see it over the span of years.
I mean,
you see their speech patterns change.
They're also tired all the time too.
That's one thing to take into consideration.
We think that it's,
you know,
that a lot of times they're all,
dude's got brain damage,
guys fucking doing three a days and he's exhausted when you talked to him,
you know,
and he's got black eyes,
so you're just assume he's got brain damage.
We want,
he's just fucking tired.
You know,
just training,
training alone,
even just doing Jujitsu one night a week,
every day,
every night is,
it kills you.
It's brutal.
But when you add in strength training and kickboxing and wrestling to all that,
I don't think there's an athlete on the planet that works as hard as mixed
martial arts fighters.
I really don't.
I think it's the most difficult physically,
emotionally,
mentally,
psychologically.
I think everything about it.
It's hard.
Who among the MMA fighters that you've met or interacted with her and just know
of who are,
who have the most grueling training regimens?
George Saint Pierre,
probably he's,
he's right up there.
He's,
um,
always fit,
you know,
and yeah,
Anderson Silva and George George is never out of shape,
never takes an opponent.
Likely always stays to the game plans.
The only time he ever took an opponent lightly was Matt Serra and he got knocked
out and never did it again.
And you know,
he's a real honest guy who learns from his mistakes,
but he trains very hard,
but pretty much they all do at this point.
Rashad Evans is notoriously tough,
uh,
in,
in a training camp.
Very hard worker.
You know this John Jones kid course,
he's,
he's got a furious work ethic.
They have to the,
all the great ones have a great worker.
There's no room right now at the top levels of mixed martial arts.
There's no room for mediocrity.
There's no room,
there's no room for anybody that thinks there's are,
there are natural doesn't want to put it at a time that sport eliminates all
that shit eliminates all the luck and all the just natural talent.
That doesn't mean shit when you're fighting five,
five minute rounds,
you got a fucking train man.
You've got to train everything.
You've got to train,
wrestling,
defense,
kickboxing,
Jujitsu,
defense.
You got a train getting up from the fucking bottom.
You got to train,
take downs.
You've got to train the whole fight.
And if you don't,
someone's going to find that chink in your armor and they gonna Jack You,
there's no room anymore.
It used to be that all you had to do was be a good striker.
All you had to do is be a good wrestler.
But nowadays it's getting to that point where you just have to always be fit.
You have to always be ready.
You have to,
you know,
there's just,
it's just such an intensely close and competitive environment right now.
Yeah.
You know,
so everyone has at the top has a serious work ethic.
Cain Velasquez.
No.
Yeah,
I've seen it.
I've watched the Canon Aka d skis as you've seen him live train.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Cause I mean I trained with,
um,
do you live up Dave Camera?
Yeah,
I used to live in San Jose,
actually.
Dave Kamaria.
Maria lived at my house real and so high.
Yeah.
We had Matt in the garage and we would,
uh,
I would train in his classes at Aka.
Dude,
that's awesome.
Die.
Oh,
he's a great teacher too.
A lot of people don't realize it unless they've looked into it.
I mean,
he used to teach chess in his spare time.
He reads Noam Chomsky.
The guys were really smart,
very,
and he's very good at taking,
let's say,
a curriculum for Jujitsu and then sequencing it in a way that makes a lot of
logical sense.
There's a progression to it.
And for that reason,
I mean,
the guys who trained with him are,
let's just say you look at a low level blue belt,
they're still notoriously difficult to deal with because they don't violate
their fundamentals.
They're really,
they have that drilled into them.
Uh,
it was a great school.
I mean,
a lot of the,
obviously it can cost check says fundamentals are so important.
Yeah.
Jujitsu,
it's something that people really don't truly don't understand.
And if you,
if you train with a guy who,
you know,
may be,
isn't so technical,
it can really,
it really,
it kind of can stunt your growth,
Jujitsu practitioner,
Jujitsu.
Is it like a language in my opinion?
Yeah.
And you,
you got to learn grammar.
Yeah.
I was just gonna say the Samsung.
If you don't have the framework.
Yeah,
just amassing vocabularies and then it becomes,
becomes
an argument.
But the way I described you Jitsu,
like most people have no idea how to defend themselves against Jujitsu.
So really what it's like is them not knowing a language and you yelling at them
in that language and they just can't possibly keep up.
Right.
That's what it's like when you're in a grappling match with someone who doesn't
understand Jujitsu.
And then the guy says,
well,
you know what?
I'm going to take Jujitsu classes.
Well,
good fucking luck.
Because you know what that's like?
That's like you,
you saying,
well,
I'm going to learn English and then I'm going to tell that American comedian
what the fuck is up.
Yeah.
No,
you're not going to,
it's going to take you forever to get to his speed.
You're gonna be able to talk at that guy speed.
He's a fucking community and he stands on stage with a microphone in front of
thousands of people and he can bust out the right thing to say at a moment's
notice.
And you're going to compete with them because you're learning this new language
called English and you're gonna eventually get as good at him.
Good fucking luck.
That's what it's like when you learn Jujitsu.
Cause someone could say,
you know,
matter,
but practice in Jujitsu,
I've been doing it six months,
I'm gonna tap you now and you can just start laughing and laughing.
Cause that's actually kind of funny.
It's like you're a person who's just learning English and you want to get into
an argument with a Harvard scholar.
Yeah.
I mean that's literally what it's like,
you know?
And as,
as you get better at it,
you know,
you realize that even your level of understanding of the language pales in
comparison to other people's like,
Oh,
you know,
uh,
I've rolled with John John Machado who's a multiple time world champion and he
gave me my brown belt and he's a great guy and a good friend.
But Rowan,
hem is like,
he's a master,
he's a master.
And you just feel like it's so fucking Claude.
Like,
why did I have my arm there?
Why is my leg here?
I know what I'm doing.
I've been doing this for 20 years.
Almost doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
Oh look,
you're mounted.
Oh,
what's that?
A triangle.
A better tap.
The world's going black shit and then you do it again and you can tap you
whatever he wants to.
Man,
he could just keep doing it.
You're getting your,
you wrote with a guy like Marcello Garcia.
It's like you're doing chopsticks and he's playing Beethoven with six arms.
You know?
It's like you can't just fucking,
there's no way.
It is like a language.
It is
totally,
as I remember,
I've been recently getting to know for a host of weird reasons,
people in the hedge fund world and I recently got out of the public markets
completely like I don't,
I'm not trading any stocks.
And part of the reason was that I remember this guy saying to me at one point,
he's like,
would you ever play poker grants a professional poker player?
It's like,
would you put million of your own money down and play that guy?
I was like,
absolutely nice.
Like,
okay,
would you put a million of your money down and play Tiger Woods in golf?
Was like,
of course not.
He's like,
okay,
well why would anyone do that with their money?
And then think they compete against the guy who runs $20 billion in a hedge fund
in the public markets.
It's the same thing.
And I was just like,
that's a good point.
I think.
I'll think I'll opt out of that.
Uh,
but uh,
yeah,
some of got to be Marcello.
So Marcello was school.
He,
he opened with Marcello Garcia.
Yeah.
With,
with Josh waste.
So Jj is,
Josh has a good friend of mine.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Awesome guy.
And he's very,
he's a very good roller too.
He's great.
Good on the mass.
But I mean,
Marcello is,
people don't understand.
Let's explain who Josh is.
Josh is the guy who was the inspiration for the movie searching for Eddie
Fisher.
Uh,
yeah.
Lobster fishery.
The fishery searching for Bobby Fisher about the chess.
Prodigy has pros about Josh.
Yeah,
it's about Josh.
So Josh has a,
Hey,
you know,
world class chess player,
he,
he's done the simultaneous exhibitions where we'll play like 40 games at once
and we'll just go from board to board to board the board.
That's such a trip.
Uh,
and a mind fuck that is,
you're a little fucking retard,
you know,
land play
in mind.
Trying to like what's his next move going to be?
What your next moves and he's walking through a room,
there's sick click,
click,
click.
Probably Awhile Song is playing in his head at the same time.
It's a trap.
It's amazing.
I've seen him,
uh,
I,
I've seen him play,
why not really play chess?
Teach chess.
He one time to the Rizza of Wu Tang clan and a WHO's really into chess.
And so they were,
they were going through opening,
opening moves.
I remember they went about 15 moves into the game,
not even like 10 moves into the game and Jessica was aren't,
let's take a look at what just happened.
And he just like pressed reverse and went back one move at a time and then could
jump forward three moves.
And uh,
that just blew my mind.
And he and
Billy can,
it's like a language.
It's like you and I communicating with readily available nouns and verbs to us.
It's a normal thing to him.
The language of chasses is just so ingrained in his mind is just so cool.
It's such a,
a game for thinkers to chasses.
It's such an impressive game to get good at because everyone I know that's truly
great.
A chasse is fucking brilliant.
Yeah.
When I was playing pool back in the day when I was,
when I first moved to New York,
I had a real pool addiction and uh,
I hung out with this pool executive billiards in white plains.
I was there every day.
And one of the things I've found,
there was guys who had been to prison who learned how to play chess in the air.
They would just talk,
they would say,
you know,
night to queen five or whatever the fuck it is.
And they would play chess standing in front of each other,
back and forth.
And one of the kids that used to come there,
this is a young kid,
I forget his name,
Adam,
I believe his name was,
he was a chess champion,
a young a chess champion.
And his father used to take him to Geez chess tournaments and stuff like that.
And he used to sit in the pool hall.
It became addicted to pool too.
And he was just sitting in the pool hall and play chess with this guy who was
this older dude who had been to jail.
And he had learned how to play chess in the air too.
So they would just sit there staring at each other and the kid would just
checkmate them left and right out of the air.
Wow.
Who's fucking amazing.
It's just so weird to think that some is like they were speaking the language.
I totally didn't understand.
Like,
I know that you,
you know,
I know that you move the rook like this and I know you moved the night like
that.
I know,
I know that,
but when there are rattling off those numbers and I'm trying to piece together
the grid and um,
you know,
I had no information in front of me,
so I was like,
okay,
how many pieces are there on a fucking chest playing battleship without a boy?
You know,
I'm on a simpler level.
Yes.
So impressive.
I'm so impressed by people who are good at chess and it transfers,
it transfers as well.
Like the,
the logical thinking.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
So I mean the,
uh,
you know,
don't go for a submission or what does it position before submission.
I mean,
that's like,
oh yeah.
I mean there are different styles of chess,
but definitely thinking strategically so that you,
you dominate certain positions,
certain,
certain directions and so forth.
I mean,
it's,
I think it's very analogous,
I guess.
Did you Jitsu?
I'm scared of it.
I'm scared of chess.
Like I'm scared of golf.
Yeah.
I'm scared of anything that I think that I might get addicted to.
And I like,
I used to listen to Howard stern talking about chess all the time.
It became a chest nut for awhile and he was taking lessons and shit.
I was like,
that is what I don't need in my life.
I don't need to be online playing fucking chest 10 hours a day.
Cause that shit could happen.
Yeah.
Well that's,
that's why,
you know,
people,
uh,
I don't watch much TV and they're like,
oh,
you one of these guys who's like,
well I don't watch TV.
I'm like,
no,
no.
You don't understand.
People are like,
Oh,
you should watch lost.
It's the best thing I've ever seen.
Or you should watch the wire.
I'm like,
look,
the reason I won't watch it is because I think it will be the best thing I've
ever seen.
And then I have to sit in a fucking cave and watch like 20 weeks of this and
then that's going to lead me to whatever you know,
six feet under and it's like I can't afford to have that happen.
I used to play d and D,
I know I can go off the off the rails.
You can d is the number one thing for going off the rail.
Right.
Everquest was another one.
What's an off the rails and he's like,
I'm a where we were last night and he would tell you,
Ari and I went to dinner last night,
a Denny's after we did the ice house.
So we're going to start doing the ice house in Pasadena all the time now folks
that fucking places.
Awesome.
And we're also going to do a podcast from the Ice House that we're going to call
it an evening at the ice house.
And what it's going to be is just,
we're going to set up microphones and a table and we're just going to have the
comic shoot the shit before they go on stage and then come off stage and shoot
the shit again.
Like,
oh,
this fucking crowds awesome.
Or there's this drunk bitch.
The front won't shut the fuck up and we're going to sit down and do this.
Um,
so what,
what was my point?
What was I talking about?
Video Games or something happened,
you went to Denny's with our,
oh,
we went to Denny's.
That's right.
Sorry.
So after the show,
we went to Denny's and they're all playing magic.
The gathering is this packet.
That's a whole,
this is not white.
Pasadena is okay.
There's a,
a giant table of dorks and they seem very nice.
I'm sorry if I call you dorks,
if you're a podcast fan,
but they're,
they're sitting down there and they all have their things that they're like,
well,
this spell has to bring,
this is the bottom of the barrel spell.
This brings you back to the law.
And I'm sitting there watching these guys and they are in their own world.
We're staring at them.
And I'm like,
the moment they look up and realize I'm staring,
I'm going to feel like an asshole.
They never looked up.
We just looked at each other and they were absorbed in their darkish fucking
magic,
the gathering games,
stacks of cards and their table and dice and they were just,
you know,
eating moons over my Hammy at three o'clock in the morning on a Friday night
villain.
Would you be into that magic?
The gathering?
It's a,
it's very immersive.
I mean I remember playing magic,
the gathering walnut or no,
not magic for me and it's,
I came before I was advanced d and D and I was all about great elves and a
number of other things.
I felt like I was very,
I was a racist.
I was like,
I was all about the,
the,
the grail for race.
But I remember at one point this friend of mine,
because I built up this pretty fucking bad ass character and this buddy of mine
is playing with me and then we had the dungeon master,
right?
Who's kind of like the referee and my buddy took it really seriously,
but he's just being a dick.
He was like bitching and whining.
You've been doing it all day and so dungeons and none of know about all sorts of
other stuff.
And he kept on bitching as we were playing.
And so we're supposed to be going on this module together.
We're supposed to be like going through this labyrinth together and at one point
my turn and I say,
okay,
I'm going to take my fucking like Mithril dagger and Stab Nick Right
in the face.
And Nick's like,
Wah,
Wah Wah.
And so I rolled and I just killed this character.
I was so pissed and he flipped and stab me in the thigh with a pencil.
Uh,
yeah,
he went absolutely homicidal.
Wow.
Where's that guy today?
He's actually really successful in New York City,
so I don't know.
It wasn't the worst thing.
He eight this Sunday.
His name Duncan Trussell.
He's really successful.
He stabbed you with a fucking pencil and the thought that you're sitting right
next to each other.
Imagine.
How old was he at the time?
He was probably say 12 or 13 oh,
okay.
I thought you were going to say.
Yeah,
but in his defense you wouldn't stop fucking with them.
You were sitting behind him poking him while he was in?
No,
no,
no.
We're not going to talk about this.
No,
no,
no.
We're not going to talk about this and that.
This is a ridiculous one.
You want just got fucked and he stabbed you with a pen because he had to get you
to stop fucking with them.
Yeah,
but if I were sitting in the front,
it messed up.
You're sitting behind him poking and while I was trying to sleep and he fucking
stabbed whatever it was,
you didn't want you to know the story.
I know the story.
I know he stabbed you in the hand because you were an annoying,
that's what was going on.
Okay.
You were in knowing him and you wouldn't stop,
so he stabbed you in the hand of the pen.
I just find it weird that people take it to the next level hand or head,
hand,
hand.
She's this
really aggressive to the next level.
But also people should stop fucking with people when they say,
stop snacking with me.
I know you didn't expect that.
I know you didn't expect that,
but I didn't want to talk about it.
Now here we are.
God dammit.
Yeah.
Dudes can get wrapped up in any kind of gay man.
I've seen violence after pool games.
I've seen violence after to basketball games.
You know,
competitive people get apparently like Michael Jordan.
If you beat him at fucking anything,
beat him at checkers.
He won't talk to you for like a month.
Yeah.
There's a,
there's one guy who shall remain nameless.
He's in as a venture capitalist in Silicon Valley,
very famous guy.
He likes to play chess and he's,
no,
not Kevin,
but he's famous.
He's very good chess player.
But if someone beats him,
he swipes all the pieces off the board and at one point someone is like,
Whoa,
you're really bad lizard.
And he goes,
show me a bad loser and I'll show you a fucking loser.
This blind.
But yeah,
it does not lose.
Show you a good loser.
Oh,
that's right.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Show me a good loser and I'll show you fucking lizard.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Gas But utilize,
you don't have to be like,
I mean for,
yeah,
for every stereotype that you have in a given industry,
like for example,
a lot of people think that in order to be a good chef,
you have to be a fucking asshole.
Like you have to be willing to fucking curse at people and make them cry in the
kitchen.
And that's,
I think a dominant trait.
But you can always find exceptions.
You can always find people who are like,
all right,
I came from a frickin abused family and the last restaurant that I was brought
up in,
and I'm not going to have that in my restaurant.
And they make it work.
You like,
you don't have to do that.
There's a funny episode of one of those kitchen shows were Gordon Ramsey was
yelling at this guy calling them an idiot.
And the guy just goes,
I ain't no bitch.
Don't talk to him either.
And he throws his thing down and he got right and Gordon Ramsay's face
and he's like,
yeah,
I thought so.
What the fuck you talking bout?
You create?
And then Gordon Ramsey was like,
you're being ridiculous.
Like Oh,
I'm being ridiculous.
Don't talk to me like that.
Stupid.
And then they separated him and pulled the guy away.
But it's true.
Gordon Ramsay's acting like this guy's an idiot.
He's going to kick his ass.
He's threatening him,
is yelling at him and the guys are like fuck you stupid.
You know,
fuck you and your fucking ridiculous way of communicating.
How bout I Trump you?
You want to go champ?
I'll go chip back.
How about that?
Oh,
you weren't set up for a reply.
He just set up to be a shithead.
I think those shows are gross.
When I hear those guys yelling at people,
I'm praying someone punches them.
That's what people were supposed to do.
And you act completely out of line like that and act like a shit head.
People were supposed to hit you.
Yeah.
Has never been hit no then but no properly.
And so when they think they're gone to the fucking panic,
they lock up.
Like all of a sudden this posturing,
all this screeching they'd been doing is ineffective and it's come down to
crunch time.
There's a line in the sand.
Will they cross it?
Yeah,
Lord of the flies,
man,
I'm a fleecy and people ask me what I am.
I'm like,
I think people behave as well as their circumstances and allow them to,
yeah,
I'm amazed.
Society keeps it together as well as it does.
The electricity is almost always on.
Everything runs smoothly.
Food arrives in time,
but God damn it,
if it did and things would go ugly so quick.
There's
a,
I saw a sign on the way over here that said,
uh,
I think it's,
it's cert training,
CRT,
which is the disaster response training.
And there's one in northern California called nerd that sews the northern
California emergency response training.
And if you do that,
they,
they prepare you for the most likely type of disaster scenario in your area.
And in San Francisco,
of course,
it's a,
among other things,
earthquake.
And I remember doing this was done by the fire department and Police Department
and they said,
all right,
how many people live in San Francisco?
Eight hundred thousand nine hundred thousand in the city,
like Greater San Francisco,
whatever it is,
7 million.
4 million.
Said,
all right,
how many firetrucks you think we have people that like 50 a hundred 120 and
they're like,
we have 12 firetrucks or something like that.
It was so small.
So they said if we get hit by a seven point,
whatever Richter scale earthquake,
what do you think the response time is going to be like?
No one is coming to save you.
So you can be without water for seven,
10 days.
And these following scenarios,
and it's like the first day or two people are gonna behave and then people are
gonna get their knives and their guns and take your water.
So that's true.
And this is,
their children are starving.
Oh yeah.
And this is,
you know,
they're giving this type of,
and they're like,
so just to get that out of the way and now we can move on to actually what to
do.
But when you get the disaster recovery or assistant certification,
you get hardhat,
uh,
one of those yellow emergency vests,
you get a special badge.
So hypothetically,
if you were to want to evacuate during this type of emergency,
if you have all of that gear and let's say a motorcycle,
she can get through traffic,
you're actually very well prepared.
So that was a,
I'm friends with Neil Strauss who's down here who wrote the game.
Uh,
emergency emergency was about a lot of this.
But the more I look at the realities of how people behave in
situations where there are scarce resources,
especially water,
the more I think that stuff is not entirely crazy.
You know,
to have six months of canned food.
I just don't,
I think it's cheap insurance now.
You can go off,
you can go off the deep end and start doing crazy,
crazy stuff,
but get those pallets of freeze dried astronaut meals delivered to your house.
And you guys with generators and then they have underground,
uh,
let's see,
what is the electromagnetic pulse?
EMP electromagnetic pulse proof boxes to hold the backup chips.
Cause it's because a number up there,
quite a few people who think one of the more likely attacks if someone wanted to
really wipe out a lot of,
uh,
functioning in the u s is to attack computer systems.
So they would drop,
let's say an electromagnetic pulse bomb in one of the Great Lakes and take out
like,
you know,
Chicago or whatever.
Whoa.
Wait a minute.
Hold up.
Yeah.
What the fuck is electromagnetic pulse bomb?
So I,
I'm thinking I'm getting this right.
And Google would,
would tell us quickly,
but it's fine.
It's something that does not,
it doesn't kill humans,
but it's,
and it fries,
it will fry all the computers,
all the generators,
everything else.
Why throw it in the great legs?
Why don't I just drop it on Chicago?
Uh,
because I think it,
uh,
what,
what the hell was the rationale?
That would just be easier to do if you're on top of water.
So you could actually,
you wouldn't even necessarily have to,
you know,
drop it.
You could just send it out in a boat.
The only thing that has something on it as above top secret,
that's like the top one always does a number one.
And then there's how stuff works.
Videos.
Nice.
There's a how to video on how to build an electromagnetic pulse.
Fun.
I always love the Internet for that road.
Apparently North Korea has this nice test missiles for electromagnetic pulse
weapon,
these mother fuckers.
So the reason I know a lot about this stuff as you meet,
you know,
these eccentric,
uh,
not a bad way,
but eccentric,
very brilliant,
very wealthy people and like they have a contingency for the contingency for the
contingency.
And this is something that's come up again and again and again.
Um,
I can't take it that far for a host of reasons,
including financial,
but I'm like,
all right,
like maybe having some basic defense and food and water in place,
maybe not a bad idea if I'm going to live in San Francisco on the ring of fire
is crazy.
Just get the extended warranty.
To this.
Right.
Bomb is crazy.
Listen to this shit.
The field of modern warfares never cease to amaze me in amongst more interesting
weapons that I've read about.
Had to be the emp bomb,
which disables all forms of electronics,
was within the vicinity.
South Korea has just developed an advanced electromagnetic pulse device,
which is cable being deployed on the battlefield in order to make short work of
enemy computers according to the defense official.
Wow.
So they really can do it.
They've developed it.
That's insane.
Yeah,
very much so.
Wild stuff man.
It's wild world.
We live in and a,
I've gone from thinking that all of that was just conspiracy theory or people
with too much time on their hands to realizing that,
you know,
for a couple hundred bucks you can actually buy herself a lot of insurance
against worst case scenario.
So like I think,
do you like living in San Francisco?
Cause that's a tricky town if you want to talk about disasters is that fucker
burns when earthquakes,
it burns.
Every house is connected.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
I'm,
I've positioned myself close,
actually very close to one of the main freeways and,
uh,
also very close to a large park,
but it is tricky,
tricky city.
Uh,
given the,
how things are architected and also just the geography of the city itself,
it's pretty hard to get out of.
So if you want,
if you have to get to,
let's say a private airport or an airstrip or something to get out of,
let's say California,
you have to plan ahead for that type of thing.
Uh,
the,
but for me,
I mean,
San Francisco,
I've lived all over the place and I've been to so many countries,
35 or so countries.
Never thought I would land somewhere and say,
this is where I'm going to live.
I always thought it was six months,
six to 12 months.
I get bored.
Then I move on.
We may just stay in San Francisco.
The cock besides the Mitchell brothers.
Yeah.
Right.
Easy access.
A little orphan.
Andy's,
we need a,
yeah,
so that's strong weed.
I would say sharks.
Sharks.
I went to the Fairland islands once.
That's a fucking creepy story I saw.
Kill.
I saw like a 400 pound seal get hit on the water on the surface.
Yeah.
That was trippy before.
Great Way.
Yeah.
Before getting into a cage and a lot of great whites out there,
man.
You know the tide ocean between Alcatraz in San Francisco.
Yeah.
It's Sharkey.
Uh,
but the Hia San Francisco,
it would be immediate access to beautiful nature everywhere.
Uh,
the startup seniors,
the creative vibe there is
to very intelligent city.
I recorded one of my cds there.
Shiny,
happy Jihad.
I think it's my,
you know,
that's this one right?
Is that the current bout to blow up the thing.
It's one of my favorite cities of all time.
It's such a bright city.
They seem so more in tune and open minded.
Just on average.
You know,
I always said that a boulder is like a frozen San Francisco.
A little bit yellow.
Very similar.
Yeah.
And it's also an Austin is sort of like Justin's very similar to San Francisco.
Super similar.
Austin has its own vibe though.
Yeah,
they have,
they've more barbecue,
more music.
San Francisco has the food though.
That's another reason I really love San Francisco is I,
the last stat I heard was something like,
so you have 800,000 people in San Francisco.
I think there are 4,000,
uh,
restaurants.
That's insane.
If you live in the city.
I live in the city,
but sort of down in the near the mission.
So I told you about living in northern California,
like a little further away,
maybe even,
um,
in a wooded Carmel,
beautiful checkout Morin.
Morin County is gorgeous right over the golden gate.
It's beautiful.
Like Mill Valley.
Where is it?
Nice.
But with less people,
uh,
up in Marin and then you're close to San Francisco,
it's 15 minutes away.
And uh,
I mean,
mountain biking was created in Marin.
I beautiful if Mount Ham,
it's,
if I were to like,
when I get married and have kids,
uh,
or have kids,
I'm not sure about the married part,
then I can see Morin very clearly being a,
an awesome choice.
I really,
yeah,
it's beautiful.
I mean,
you've surfing,
you have everything,
it's gorgeous and you're close to Tahoe.
You close to nappy or close to,
uh,
you have 70.
It's,
it's a,
it's a great look.
It's amazing how some parts of the country actually geographically become
awesome spots.
You know,
it's like,
it is not just a weather thing,
it's just like some,
some places are great spots,
you know,
I mean w w you know,
the factors that come into to making a Boston or a Seattle or as opposed to a
Paducah,
Kentucky or you know,
Wilmington Delaware or something.
You know,
it's interesting how some spots are just like way better places to live in San
Francisco for the,
as far as creativity and mind and thinking and people,
it's a great spot.
Great.
Like the spot defined interesting thinkers.
It is.
And what I really like about it is,
and it's not true for everybody of course,
but there's very much a,
don't judge a book by its cover via ethos because you just,
you don't know who the college kid is who's unemployed or the billionaire.
They could both be wearing the same thing.
You have no idea.
And I remember at one point I went into best buy,
I remember to buy my first like real TV,
still have it.
This is,
I don't know if I 10 years ago.
So anyway guys,
I love it.
Anyway,
went in and the sales guy was great.
He's like,
come back in a couple of days,
this other managers,
terrible negotiator and get a better price.
It's like,
fantastic.
I love you already.
I'm going to buy a lot of stuff from you.
But he told me a story.
He said a lot of my uh,
you know,
he was African American and lived in East Palo Alto.
He said a lot of my coworkers,
they want to go for the guy in the suit and he's like,
I always want to go for like the slightly scraggly early forties white dude and
like the torn jeans and flip flops.
And he did that.
At one point they were like,
take back,
I,
we don't want him.
And so he took,
this guy ended up being the founder of Ikea and he's like,
yeah,
I'll get 10 of those flat screens,
I'll get 15 of those.
And he was buying shit for the Ikea that Ge just opened next door.
And uh,
so this guy just,
you know,
I made,
he's quoted for the next decade as a whole,
is pretty awesome.
You still have this Sony Wagga because it weighs 5,000 pounds.
It's really,
I can't,
I can't move the thing I got to work on my dead lift.
It's a bit,
well,
it's certainly not a flat screen.
I mean it's a flat front flap front and then it's just a cathode ray tube.
The thing is,
it's like a refrigerator.
I kept him a hold of mine probably like three years longer than I wanted to just
because every time I tried to move I'm like,
yeah,
I'm not going to,
I just can't get here.
Yeah.
So heavy.
I remember watching hi death,
uh,
animal planet fish.
That was the fuck I brought it home.
I turned it on and I landed on that and I was just like,
I cannot fucking believe how worth it was.
How long was it?
It was to get HD for the underwater stuff.
Just blew my brands.
Ever watched that Earth series,
gorgeous planet earth.
Oh man,
fucking the breaching the great whites in South Africa.
Oh my Lord.
Great White.
Scare the fuck out of me,
man.
They've been spotting them out here at Malibu to really recently.
It spotted them from helicopters and people flying over.
They see,
they look down,
they see just big 1820 foot sharks.
That's no joke.
I was in,
I was in South Africa.
Check this out.
I'm so,
I love sharks.
I want to be a marine biologist for Longterm Merriam.
Sorry
if I find a hot enough,
great wine.
We went,
my brother and I went to this place called Fish Hook Hoek and my brother wanted
to surf and so we landed there.
It was really choppy.
The traffic was terrible.
We got there close to five o'clock.
The guys like,
guys,
we're about to shut up shop,
but if you really want to go out there,
it's pretty shitty conditions,
but I'll give you a board and give you a discount.
And I was like,
ah,
Tom,
I don't want to surf for 20 minutes.
He really wanted to be argued.
And then eventually just went for a cup of coffee about,
uh,
20 minutes later,
a guide down the beach got bitten in half in neck deep water by a 16 foot great
white shark.
What's even crazier is one of my,
uh,
readers was the first guy to,
he tweeted it out,
he basically said,
holy fucking shit.
Just so like I get bitten in half by great white shark.
So you look down at your Twitter,
you see that and you realize that could have been,
you could have been me easily.
And found out later that the shark spotters at that beach,
they have guys with binoculars.
They'd spotted eight great whites at that beach.
Wow.
And,
and then people just go right back up.
They're like,
okay,
clear,
great.
And they go back out to surf and I fuck is wrong with you people.
I know.
Well that's good.
Is Surfing,
is it that good?
It is good.
But as far as I'm concerned,
not that good.
I mean in the sense that it's,
it's world class surfing,
but his world is surfing in any respect.
Worth better.
Yeah.
And it's only cold water though,
right?
They can go there usually in temperature,
colder waters.
Like in Brazil they surf a lot but they don't have to worry about sharks.
Right and well it depends on where you are.
This place called hissy fit and Brazil where I went to visit at one point and
they have signs there that are fantastic,
but they used to have a meet candidate and not meet Ken and what was it?
Yeah,
like canneries right at this one delta where it opens up into the ocean.
And so these bull sharks and he's like entire communities of bull sharks have
devolved there and they're very aggressive sharks and the signs on the beach,
if you see them in the u s usually it's like morning sharks.
Sharks have been spotted at this area.
Use Caution and talk to your lifeguard,
whatever.
And the signs in Brazil where like don't go in the water,
you'll get fucking attack basically.
And people still surf there and it's like Guy with one arm still surfing.
He's like,
well we're in their backyard.
And I'm like,
and maybe you should pick a different sport,
their backyard PA sharks.
To me,
I've always been one of those things where if they didn't exist and you had him
in a movie,
everybody would be fucking horrified of these things,
but because of the fact that they're real,
just like Komodo dragons are,
crocodiles are killer whales,
we just sleep on these things.
We don't realize how incredibly fascinating and horrifying they really,
oh yeah.
Well that's why I was telling you that fucking line attack video.
Shoot the shit I need because I just,
I think to myself,
somebody was asking me at one point,
they're like,
you think you could kill this animal or that animal?
Like,
no,
like Badger,
that thing would fuck me.
I'm not going to kill a badger.
You crazy like do I don't have claws.
Like what do you think I'm going to do?
Let's have a weapon.
Like I kicked the fuck out of a badger.
I'll tell you that right now and you can give me some skilled steel toed boots
and a strong a Kevin or a pair of pants.
I'll fuck a badger up.
I'll stomp that little bitch.
If you have chain,
go after a lot of things.
If I had a good baseball bat and a steel tip,
boots a fuck up,
a Badger Lodo Dragon.
When you take a Komodo dragon on,
no,
you're fucked.
You're doomed.
There's nothing you can do because they're close enough to bite you.
That's your ass.
There's so fast.
It's so fast and they have botulism and they're fucking saliva.
Catch deer.
There's so fast.
It's hard.
It's hard to believe.
And when they bite things,
all they do is bite them and then follow them.
They wait for the poison in their saliva to eventually just toxify their whole
body,
their body just,
it's just,
it's like there's their own soul.
The nasty bacteria in their mouth just fucks animals.
As soon as they bite them,
they,
they're like,
take a water buffalo.
They bite them and they follow him for 24 hours and then slowly he just buckles
and then they just eat his asshole while he's alive cause dig in and pull chunks
of amount.
Komodo dragons are terrifying.
Or do they live Komodo islands?
I've only one island in Indonesia.
There's a nutty animal man.
You know,
it's uh,
you see that crocodile,
they just caught in the Philippines.
Yeah,
I did.
Holy Shit.
And they're like,
this is going to be the star of our new zoo because it's the silk impoverished
Filipino feelings.
Yeah.
I'd say normally set up a bunch of traps for this thing and it broke all their
traps and it killed a fisherman,
a local fishermen.
That thing is 21 feet long.
God dammit.
How crazy these things,
crocodiles,
perfect example.
If they weren't real and then you know,
and there was stories of this thing that you know,
it can hold its breath for hours and water buffalo and he'd be like,
get the fuck out here.
That's how big that is.
It's looking at this room.
It's like from that,
that's insane.
Bigger than this room.
Yeah.
It's bigger than,
it's not a,
and it's not like a slender animal.
I mean the back is like this.
It's like up to naval height and they are all wrapped this fucking thing up.
All these little Lilliputians took this Gulliver travel fucking animal down and
tied it up and ropes and they were parading it around the town.
It's crazy to see,
man.
It's fucking monster.
Have you ever seen Hogzilla?
Yes.
Shit.
If you ever seen it Brian.
It sounds familiar but I don't know.
Well in Georgia and a lot of farm the size of a Volkswagen beetle,
it's fucking cute.
It's a pig.
It's a super,
well,
it's,
it's a cross between a wild boar and uh,
a feral hog and pigs of,
a lot of people don't realize this,
but pigs are one of the strangest animals known to be in,
in captivity because when they get out,
they have a physiological change.
When they go into the wild,
as soon as you're not feeding them anymore,
they changed their appearance,
their tusks grow,
their snout elongates and their hair gets shaggy and thick and it starts
happening three weeks after they come free.
Yeah.
That's like a whereabouts.
It is like a werewolf.
When you have that pig that's in your style and he's got white hair and he's all
cute and pink and he comes over and dozens against you and you could pat him on
the head and in Nice piggy,
piggy.
When that pig goes out into the woods,
his nose stretches out,
his hair gets furry and its fangs grow.
That's fucking terrible.
It could be a grown pig,
it can be a fully grown pig,
but once it gets out into the wild,
there's a physiological change.
When they become feral.
It's very interesting.
They're domesticated versions.
They have a change of,
uh,
there were actual appearance,
biology changes.
It's pretty trippy,
man.
You know that.
A random side note,
but a auxiliary,
and I'm putting it up right now.
Have you?
We didn't explain what it is.
It's showed it.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
Shot the,
have you ever read born to run?
No.
Really good book.
But it talks about of the evolution of mankind and there are a lot of theories,
but they,
they,
one of the theories is that part of the reason we evolved and were able to kill
animals that provided more protein,
which led to a larger brain,
et Cetera,
is one is a bigger one than that is one where the guy standing with a rifle is
that we could run on two legs while keeping our heads steady.
And it's because of this,
like I think it's a nuchal ligament at the base of the skull,
which is unique to humans.
And if you look at a pig for example,
when it runs a ted,
Bob's all over the place,
like a bobble head and then that they know hominids or Homo sapiens develop that
nuchal ligament that allowed them to like endurance,
run after animals and kill and secure more protein,
pretty well supported or Ron is a great book,
highly recommend it.
It's fascinating to me when they try to go back in time,
like they'd recently found some,
uh,
pro hominid skeletons that were one point
like the,
the,
the whole,
uh,
origin of the species into question.
It's fascinating to me when they just go back in time and discover these things,
like top of those little hobbit people that they've recently found like that
existed as recently as like 15,
20,000 years ago.
There's a little tiny three foot tall hobbit,
like people,
I love this stuff.
I love when they don't know and then all of a sudden some new thing comes up and
then go,
oh,
whoa.
There,
I guess there were using tools a million years ago.
Yeah.
Like fuck.
And I like that.
Oh,
I guess they were domesticating livestock.
Here's the thing.
They figured out recently in Saudi Arabia,
they've found clear evidence of the domestication of horses 6,000 years early
and they previously thought people were doing it.
So now they're like,
holy fuck.
Like,
you know,
you've heard of disco Beckley tappy have you heard of this?
No.
Well,
it's,
this is a site.
It's a site in Turkey.
Oh,
I have heard of that.
Yeah.
I don't know the details,
but I recognize the archeological discoveries,
1520 foot high pillars of,
of,
of a,
of stone been carved
along with animals that aren't even living on this continent.
So they're like,
what the fuck,
man,
these animals aren't even from here.
How the hell are these guys?
Yeah.
Why are these on these things?
What,
what is this 12,000 year old complex structure that we find and there's still an
earthing and they discovered it in the 90s and they'd been slit,
like a farmer,
like stumbled upon this thing and then started digging.
It was like,
what the fuck is this?
And then he realizes that giant stone pillar and this whole community had been
on purpose.
Someone had buried it.
It's almost like they made a little time capsule and they covered it.
They're pretty positive that it was a manmade act of,
of covering it and that they,
someone covered it thousands and thousands of years ago and they just luckily
stumbled upon it.
So while it's amazing the stuff that blows my mind too was thinking of the
actual mechanics,
like the mechanical engineering that someone would have to use to put up these
pillars or like Stonehenge or things like that.
It's like how the fuck?
Well,
even how about stone management used?
We don't understand who made Stonehenge,
but we don't know who made Egypt.
We know these are,
these are the people.
This is the writing.
How'd they get that obelisk up there?
What the fuck ban?
We know those people did it.
It's written.
It has all of their language from the top to the bottom.
It's all written in there.
Hieroglyphs so what the fuck,
man?
How did you do that while things enormous.
Some of those perfectly cut obelisks.
Those are almost as fascinating to me is the pyramid because the pyramid,
yeah,
the stones are all big,
but you know,
did you push it in place?
It's all a matter of how did you play?
It was just one stone.
I'd be like,
that's not that big of a deal.
And so you moved one stone.
It's the fact that he moved 2 million,
300,000 of that makes me,
it makes you think that's amazing,
but the obelisks just one,
just one of them.
You're like,
what the fuck?
How did you do that?
How the fuck did you make that giant stone thing with all the carving,
50 fucking feet tall men at a one piece of stone,
Jesus Christ.
Some of those amazing structures of Pharaohs that are like 2030 feet high and
you're looking at them,
you're like,
who the hell what the fuck?
5,000 years ago,
6,000 years ago they were doing this.
The ones that blew my mind too,
or the aqua ducts that were made in Roman times.
It's still work
as nuts.
Human Ingenuity,
man.
Do you subscribe to the idea,
and this is a reoccurring subject on this podcast that humanity has gone through
cycles of,
of like really high levels of understanding and knowledge and then cataclysmic
disaster or human based disaster.
Oh,
for sure.
You think so?
Oh yeah.
I mean,
I think if you look at the Roman empire and you look at the,
the growth and decline of the US empire,
it's parallel after parallel,
after parallel distributing military is one of the first symptoms of like
proceeding the decline.
I think point for point.
You can look at these,
these meteoric rises and then catastrophic,
uh,
false.
And it's just like a pulse.
It's like a breathing in and breathing out.
It is a complicated cycle and it's almost inevitable.
I mean I've,
but is it always because of,
you know,
obviously,
right,
right now in the stage we're at with,
you know,
we talk about military talk about depletion of the resources,
the polluting the planet.
This is almost all active things that we can control.
But what about giant things that happened shifting of the polarized caps,
asteroid impact,
things along those lines that very likely have had,
we believe,
at least I think they think five mass extinctions in the history of the planet.
And who knows how many little baby ones along the way.
Like that one that you drive to Nevada and you see that mile wide crater,
that's like nothing.
Oh,
it's only a mile.
You know,
it was probably only like 15 feet long,
but meanwhile,
everything from miles around near that thing was dead instantly,
you know?
I mean,
how many of those hit all over the place and we were just not aware of because
it was 10,000 years ago and now it's covered in jungle wherever the impact was.
So yeah.
You know,
I mean if we're having trouble tracking the,
the evolution of our own species,
yeah,
yeah.
The amount of,
I think the limits of our knowledge of this planner are so incredibly vast,
you know,
to think that I,
I think there are also very natural cycles.
If you look at just population growth,
for example,
you look at elderly economies and how that affects their rise and decline in
Japan,
uh,
negative growth rates,
places like in certain countries in Europe,
uh,
you can just predict this stuff like in a 10,
20 years out.
And,
uh,
but I think that things grow and then they die.
That's just the cycle.
And you can apply that to people.
You could apply it to just about any life form.
You can also apply it to a companies.
You can apply it to countries.
If you had to extrapolate,
okay,
what we know now is that we had a bunch of disenfranchise Europeans and various
people from all over the world.
They found this spot that just 10,000 years ago it had been covered with a mile
high sheet of ice.
You know,
the,
the climate shifts.
All of a sudden North America becomes viable property.
Everybody moves here.
We established this new sort of a civilization.
The,
the what we believe is the most advanced or the percolating at the highest
levels.
You know,
when it comes to a military and money and economy and you know,
and creativity.
This one pile called the United States.
If you had to extrapolate and look at the trends and look at what's next,
what do you think could be nice?
Cause I mean this is a place that was created just a few lifetimes ago.
Really the 17 hundreds in the,
in the course of human history.
It's a very small amount of time.
The course of the history of the world,
it's merely a blink of an eye.
It's nothing.
But in that time,
this new type of civilization,
supposedly new type of really bullshit at the end.
I mean it becomes just as corrupt as all the other ones before,
but the idea of it,
this was the first,
this was the first in history like this.
You know that people like,
fuck where you're at,
getting a boat.
Come on over here.
We got a new spot.
We're just going to get away from those douchebags and we're going to try our
own thing out.
Is it possible that that could happen again?
Is it possible that you know some other spot opens up and people decide to do
this one more time?
I mean,
I can't imagine it,
but I do imagine it sometimes when when Bush won the second term in 2004 I'd
fucking seriously thought about moving to Canada.
I really dead.
I was like this,
this place is going to get blown up.
This crazy assholes invading all of these countries when on dubious evidence and
it turns out they lied about a bunch of different shit and weapons of mass
destruction from the moment they got in.
There was an idea to go over there and this was just what they could find a fit
their agenda and they shove all the facts and pseudo facts into one situation
just so they can force this on people.
I was like,
we're going to get blown up.
I don't want to get blown up.
I'm gonna fucking go to Canada.
Were nobody fucks with anybody.
Yeah.
I think that a lot of people,
for example,
are concerned about China and India.
So it's sort of like China versus the US and that doesn't scare me.
I'm actually very bearish on China.
But I think the what,
what is not obvious to most people is that at the highest levels of government,
private enterprise,
you have this military industrial industrial complex that spans across these
countries.
And uh,
that's the stuff that really scares me.
And having centralized food production that scares me.
What does it scare me about China is China's not trying to conquer the world
you're trying to do business,
you know?
Yeah.
I think they're doing some fucked up things to some of their towns.
As far as pollution.
China has some of the worst standards of still,
I mean,
it's horrible ceremony.
I've seen there's a video online of one city in China that you live there and
it's like through smoking three packs of cigarettes a day.
It's incredible.
They had cameras,
I believe it was one of those vice guide to TVS.
I think it was a vbs.tv doc.
And they went there and they were filming the,
the,
the air and you're looking up,
you're like,
oh my God,
this is impossible.
These people are breathing coal.
They're just breathing in colon the air.
But China's not trying to conquer the world.
They're just trying to make money.
You know,
they're trying to
be very well positioned if they do want to conquer the world because what
they've been doing.
I mean,
I was living in Argentina for a bit and then I was uh,
uh,
in Africa,
Kenya for the first time.
And they're buying,
they're very smart about acquiring resources and pipelines for petroleum and
also buying,
uh,
mine's four productions of production of things like copper.
They've been absolutely brilliant.
Um,
you go to places like Argentina,
which is the,
I think it's the eighth largest country in the world and that because of the
range from tropics,
like equals who falls in Brazil,
which borders Argentina all the way down to Antarctica.
They're very rich,
natural resources and you go there and in all the major cities you have like the
Chinese trade pro us nowhere to be found.
Then you go to Kenya and you look around like everything being built Chinese.
And it's,
uh,
it had been very smart about it.
And I think that that also,
maybe we're digressing a little bit,
but that's okay.
Is there is a benefit at times two very clear hierarchy.
And,
uh,
and having that top down type of,
I think that
democracy does have weaknesses and one of them is oftentimes speed.
So in an accelerating world,
Mussington democracy is a bad thing.
I think it's the,
you know,
one of the better systems we have,
but it's very hard to compete with a,
with a single vision.
Yeah.
With a sort of unified top down capitalists,
dictatorship.
I mean like they want to change something great like five guys,
snap their fingers and make it happen.
It doesn't have to go through the house,
doesn't then have to go through the Senate.
It doesn't have to sit around and have these lobbyists fuck with it and so forth
and so on.
And I think there are pros and cons,
but there's certainly a lot faster.
You,
the system that we have in place obviously is a fucking mess.
I just don't know how anybody would ever replace it.
And we had a guy here the other day,
Pinchbeck also believed that society is going to collapse 100% he believes that.
What does it look like when that happened?
That's what I said.
First of all,
I said,
how do you,
how can you say anything's going to happen?
100% that's one of the most silly things you could ever say because how do you
know that you're fucking head's not going to explode right there while we're
talking.
You can have an aneurysm.
Nobody knows they're coming,
you know,
they just happen.
How do you know that we're not going to get hit by a meteor?
How do we know that a comment's not going to fucking push earth off its axis too
far from the sun?
We all fucking freeze to death like shit.
Like this happens in the solar system.
You know,
it happens all the time.
All the time.
Planets hit other planets.
Galaxies collide with other galaxies and the fuck.
Can you tell him he societies 100% gonna collapse.
I mean that seems just,
that seems like really silly.
I don't think that's even close to the case.
I don't think society has to collapse.
I just think it's not going to stay this way.
I think that's pretty obvious.
It's changing.
It's moving.
It's not going to stay this way.
People are obviously fed up with the financial system that we have in place
right now,
but what are they doing about it?
What can be done?
What's the substitution they suggest?
Yeah,
I,
it's,
there's another book that was recommended to me by a guy named Matt Mullen way
could develop,
he was one of the lead developers.
It was his name again.
Matt Mullenweg.
Yeah,
a really smart guy.
And he introduced me to the Black Swan by Nassim Taleb,
which is really about rare events and how poor humans are at predicting or even
planning for rare events.
It's a great book though.
It's like a guide to critical thinking.
It's awesome.
But uh,
so the analogy that he uses in that book is,
you know,
thanks.
Just because the thanksgiving Turkey hasn't been killed for 200 days doesn't
mean it's not going to get killed.
Whereas we always do this financial markets,
relationships,
whatever it might be,
it would be like,
well,
it hasn't happened so far,
so it can't happen.
I to,
I call it the ant hill effect.
This is my,
my analogy.
I say when you see an ant hill is sitting out in the field and ant hill might've
been there for a year,
those ants might've been patiently constructing this giant mound and there's a
million ants in.
They're going to work every single day and every day that they've been alive,
that ant hills been there.
But one day there's a little fat kid in the field and he sees that ant hill and
he stomps the fucking shit out of it and not a single aunt ever sees him comment
and he's just sitting there hitting it with sticks.
He poured gasoline on it,
he lights it on fire,
he shits on it.
He pisses on it.
And why?
Because he could cause he wanted to.
And that could have happened any day.
That's the universe.
The universe is a fat kid stomping and shitting on your handheld.
I mean really,
that's what it is,
right?
It all can happen at any moment.
Yellowstone is my number one freak out.
You know the super volcano,
you don't know.
No son.
The Caldera volcano that is 300 kilometers wide it Dave,
Dave is.
It's yellow stone itself.
It's in Yellowstone.
They did not know that Yellowstone was a giant volcano,
a super volcano,
one of the ones that they call it an extinction event because it'll kill almost
everything on the continent every six to 800,000 years.
Wow.
The last time it happened was 600,000 years ago.
Oops.
So we're literally do,
and they have thousands of earthquakes in Yellowstone every year.
Literally thousands of earthquakes.
And what Yellowstone is,
is a gigantic super volcano when it called Dara volcano is,
it's a volcano that builds up and when it explodes,
it's so violent that it literally blows the top off and just becomes a flat
crater.
Like there's nothing,
just the entire volcano explodes.
The whole thing shoots up into the fucking sky and everyone dies.
You just,
it just fucks everything up.
And they realize that this happens is,
like I said,
every supposedly six to 800,000 years is a major eruption that just fucking
blows up and kills everything.
My banking on retirement 40 years,
you know,
it's not a good idea.
So you just never know.
One called there is going to fucking hate you.
In closing,
what advice would you give people if you know what,
what is the best advice that you can give someone to,
to live a fun and productive life?
I actually do another recommendation.
I would say you need to train yourself to recognize what's in your control out
of your control and then not emotionally over respond to things outside of your
control.
The best guide to that that I've ever found,
his letters from a stoic written by Seneca,
it's written 2000 years ago.
It's a series of letters,
short letters from Seneca was the most successful playwright investment banker,
advisor to the emperor as well as a philosopher of his day.
And it could just as easily apply today.
So I would say that would be,
it's a short book.
That would be my recommendation.
Well,
my,
uh,
favorite things are reading inspirational books and blog entries and listening
to books on taste by people who have done what you've done,
spent a lot of time breaking things down and there's so much insight that people
can get from your books from four hour workweek and the four hour body and the,
the videos that you put online.
I think you're doing an awesome thing man.
And,
and anybody who does things along these lines,
you're,
you're putting out all this information and you're,
you're affecting the way people think and process information and it's awesome,
man.
I think it's a great thing.
And uh,
thanks for being on,
man.
It was really cool.
Really loved talking to you.
I'd love to have you on again.
Yeah,
my pleasure.
I'd love to come back and if anybody wants to follow Tim on Twitter,
it's t,
Ferris,
t,
F,
e R,
I s s,
two r's,
two s's.
And of course red ban is red band and I'm Joe Rogan.
And the upcoming dates that we've got going on,
I'm going to be in New Orleans at September 16th.
It's almost sold out Denver,
Colorado.
On.
That's a September 16,
Denver,
Colorado on the 23rd.
That's almost sold out too.
That's at the paramount theater.
That's a big place.
And that's what Joey Diaz and Ari should fear.
And then we're going to do a Washington DC,
the Warner Center on the 30th.
That's all sold out too.
And then Houston tax has just went on sale and that's October 7th.
That's going to be the Verizon wireless theater and that's Brendan,
um,
uh,
wonder Walsh and uh,
who else is going?
Joey,
Joey Diaz,
Joey Diaz and Brendan Walsh and doing that one.
And um,
that's it.
Fuckers tomorrow night.
Uh,
Anthony Bordain same time.
3:00 PM should be a fun one.
Thank you to everybody.
Thanks for coming by the Ice House this weekend.
Like I said,
we're going to do that all the fucking time there and look for another new
podcast that we do all comedians right before we go on stage,
we're going to call it live from the ice house or an evening at the ice house or
something along those lines.
Um,
that's if bitches,
thanks the flashlight.
Go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link for the flashlight entering the code
name Brogan and you will get 15% off the number one sex toy for men.
And if you want to buy these Alpha brain pills,
the new order comes in.
This week we just had an order of half a million new pills.
Wow.
And it's um,
on@dotcomonnit.com.
And the stuff's called Alpha brain.
And it's by the way,
is a hundred percent money back guarantee.
If you don't like it,
send it back in and get your money back.
No questions asked.
So we want to make sure that everybody's happy with it.
Go Fuck Yourself.
The show's over.
That's it.
That's the thank you Tim for coming by.
I had an awesome time.
Ferriss' four hour work week,
the four hour body.
Go buy his books,
Ladies and gentlemen.
And what is your website?
Website is for our blog.com.
F O U R H O U R B l o g.com.
Our full thank you everybody.
We'll see you tomorrow with Anthony.
Boarding and training are wrong.
Come on.